so a little bit about Joe most you may
or some of you may or may not know this
native of New York he originally got his
bachelor and MS from st. John's
University and then as I mentioned did
his graduate work at Indiana University
MD ph.d after residency training and
anatomic pathology actually I got a
slider I can go full and under the
letter stage well that's I made this
very easy yeah so you can see some of
the things he's done there but did a
fellowship with Heinz Firth Meyer here
and that's where I think sparked his
first interest in matrix biology and
endothelial cells and and then join the
faculty here in 1980
rumor has that Joe can confirm I think
his generous startup package for his lab
at Yale was $5,000 - oh yeah okay huge
so we're still trying to get back to
that point that it is new hires have
been a little more expensive yeah so
this is an early picture the department
I think those of you can recognize many
of the players there I think in fact
many are in this room it's a little
scary but the next one little close-up
there's Joe and earlier this is Hines
Firth Meyer for those you recognize the
fellow that Joe trained with we don't
know him we won't talk about that one so
I think just the summarize Joe's career
a little bit Joe represents really all
that one could ask of a of a real triple
threat faculty member he's continuous
funding for 37 years from the NIH and
American Heart Association in 1999 he
was awarded a tenure merit award from
the National Institutes of Health his
studies have made major contributions to
our understanding the role of the matrix
on vascular biology on diabetes
angiogenesis neurovascular development
and most recently he's transitioned to
be a bit of a immunologist and is
looking at anti
immunity and the role of neutrophils
Jose published 272 peer-reviewed
articles and topical reviews describing
this work he's been to present these
findings are over 200 national and
international conferences and seminars
and of course as you'll hear from today
from some of the speakers Jose amassed a
very large group of outstanding
collaborators trainees and colleagues
through this period beyond his research
Jose excelled as an educator he's about
a considerable time and effort to the
teaching missions here at Yale both in
the medical school and the undergraduate
yell college course he served a director
of our director of medical education in
pathology for no less than twenty years
he was honored in 2001 by the very
prestigious chuga award of the outs for
outstanding mentorship and scholarship
by the American Association of
investigative pathologists there's only
one of these awards given each year
nationally so to receive this out of the
whole nation is quite an honor
and in his research laboratory and
you'll hear from some today Joe is
trained over 100 postdoctoral fellows MD
PhD students PhD students and
undergraduate students if this wasn't
enough he's also been an outstanding
community citizen of Yale and the
greater scientific community
he's been on multiple NIH study sections
I lost count when I was trying to figure
this out
he's been on study sections for the
American Heart Association he served as
an assistant or associate editors for
the Journal of American American Journal
of pathology laboratory investigation
the fast of journal and the journal
sailor physiology and angiogenesis he's
been on the scientific advisory boards
of the Shriners Research Institute and
the genzyme tissue repair Inc he was one
of the cofounders of alexion
Pharmaceuticals here in New Haven and
served under Advisory Board for many
years and to top all this off throughout
all this Joe's remain clinically active
as a practicing pathologist and a member
of the medical staff here at Yale New
Haven
Hospital his extracurricular Affairs Joe
has for three decades been a student of
the martial arts he was a fourth degree
black belt is an international
instructor in Taekwondo and in fact used
to practices in our conference room in
the evenings and I wondered Joe about
some of the furniture damage in that
room physically I think last and
certainly not least Joe and his wife
Lucille had been very generous
philanthropist they made major donations
to their alma mater in Indiana to city
of New Haven last year as many of you
know established an endowment for
experimental pathology here at Yale so
in so many ways this symposium we're
hosting today is a way of thanking you
Joe and your wife Lucille for all that
you've contributed over such a long time
so now it's time sit back and enjoy the
fruits of others that you had so much a
big hand in helping to bring to fruition
so very good
okay under the thing our first speaker
he's still here and she's at practicing
physician who has a I understand these
sick patients so Florida you have to
leave at any point we will understand
that I hopefully not before the next
thirty minutes our speaker is Professor
Laura mint who is a professor of
pediatrics in neurology here at Yale
she's also associate dean of admissions
Laura received her as a graduate of
Brown University and Tufts University
School of Medicine she received her
training in pediatrics at Massachusetts
General Hospital
ever since I certainly as long as I have
known her and I think since her early
stages of her career she's been
particularly interested in neonatal
brain injury and both preterm infants
and some of the consequence of that
including intraventricular hemorrhage
perivascular white matter injuries
seizures and other can such conditions
she has been the principal investigator
on multiple grants here at Yale I had
the honor of sharing on such grants with
Laura and certainly Joe and Laura had a
long-term collaboration she is they I
think as you may hear and elosha exactly
what Laura's going to be talking about
today but certainly when my knowledge as
they had worked together for many years
to develop animal models of some of the
clinical conditions that Laura was
experienced in the clinic and this has
had major impact on the care of such
infants and certainly understanding the
micro vascular niche and the way this
has guided early brain development so
without further ado we'll turn the
podium over to Laura and now change
computers got to do that too I guess
room left
I'm getting some help in the back I see
get you going here here you want to use
this flip it on okay all right all right
well I'd like to thank dr. Morel and the
organizers of this sighs wonderful
seminar for inviting me to speak I met
dr. Madhuri in the hall in front of his
lab in 1984 Bill Stewart or somewhere on
the audience sent me down to find
somebody to help us with our research
and thanks to Joe really our research
was able to take less and continue over
many years so I'm a clinician and I know
that you've been here a lot of basic
sciences basic science later but really
thanks to Joe we were able to submit a
grant a multicenter grant to study
preterm infants the prevention of
interventricular hemorrhage and what
happened to them over the years so I'm
going to tell you about imaging their
brains and I'm the person who gets to
stand up here and talk but really this
work is there in large part attributable
to Todd constable who can be with us
today but was the head of the amount
Research Center that Ybor is our
long-term collaborator at brown and then
the other people are part of Dustin part
of Todd's lab so preterm birth is really
a global pediatric public health problem
in the United States each year we have
four million deliveries of healthy
babies but almost 12% of them are born
preterm and if you're born preterm it
depends on how early you are but as many
as 50% of them have significant language
disorders so this is a major problem
when they come to school and when they
grow up
unfortunately here you we have the
opportunity to use sophisticated MRI
strategies and reviews these strategies
since 1995 to look at the preemies in
all of our studies and actually in 1995
something happened for a group that will
never happen to
again and that was is really a rarity
for NIH but they call this up and they
asked us if they would if we could image
the preemies in our in the medicine
cohort the into medicine cohort was five
hundred five babies enrolled at Maine
brown and Yale between 1989 and 1992
they weighed between 600 and 1250 grams
at birth and we followed them for over
23 years so this was a trial really
based on the work that Joe had helped us
do in the early 80s looking at
preventing interventricular hemorrhage
we took it to pilot trials here we moved
it to a multicenter trial and because we
have a large interesting cohort and it
was efficacious we were able to follow
them for many years so in 1995 and
published in 2000 we started our MRI
studies on the survivors of the
randomized in the Memphis and idh
prevention trial this is our very first
paper was done by a young man named Brad
Peterson he was a postdoc in the Child
Study Center who had learned imaging at
Mass General and what it is is a
volumetric study of preterm brains
compared to term control brains and this
is a statistical parametric map here's
the left hemisphere here's the right
hemisphere and where there's no
difference between the preterm subjects
and the term controls Itchy Oh blue so
in the back and in sort of in the front
where there's a big difference it's red
and you can see that this is the
temporal region the parietal language
lesions right were the preemies talk
over all the brain was 6% smaller in the
previous compared to the term control
but in these regions it was much as much
as 30% smaller suggesting that there was
actually a reason that we could explore
in the preemies for why they had so much
trouble with language so this is a study
that was done by a Yale medical student
I'm going to thank all the Yale Medical
have worked on this project across the
years and the residents this is Kate
Mullins she's becoming a
neuroradiologist in Boston right now she
looked at our previous when they became
16 years old and gender match term
controls Kate did diffusion tensor
imaging which is the first thing that
our MRI Research Center was doing and
she wanted to look at the language
pathways so the dorsal pathway here in
blue subserved phonology and it's just
supposed to be your left r2 it the
ventral pathway in red subservience and
that's bilateral ultimate facility at
particular right here so for those of
you who don't come to pediatric
neurology clinic every day phonology is
how you break down a word into the
component parts so when you come to my
crank and I make you say po po padiddle
that's phonology okay so what Kate
showed was that unlike the term controls
the preemies for using both hemispheres
at age 16 for phonology so either they
hadn't proved what was going on in the
right hemisphere or they had an
alternative pathway so in the next 20
minutes because John has told me I can
have 25 total I'd like to suggest that
functional studies suggest the
engagement of alternative pathways and
preterm born subjects neonatal studies
demonstrate alterations in functional
organization for language and that
language systems are actually altered
prior to birth and children born
prematurely so what we do in our in pods
lab is functional connectivity and Todd
made this slide for me so I'll make sure
that I show you everything
so these are brain regions that Todd is
randomly assigned if two regions are
functionally connected like the green
region and the brown region then they're
oscillating at the same frequency and we
say they're functionally connected if
they're oscillating at different
frequencies they are not functionally
connected so there's no in pathology
neuropathology none of you all could
dissect these out and show where they're
connected
this is purely based on physics all
right so our first hypothesis was that
preterm birth would ultra functional
conductivity for language and this is a
study that was done by JC Gaucho JC was
a resident and then a neonatology fellow
when she did the study she's now on
faculty she took forty at twenty fifty
four of our preterm subjects and twenty
four of our term controls at age eight
years they had absolutely no difference
in their language testing scores and
they had no evidence for IV h no PDL no
brain injury and she gave them the
passive listening task they wore
headphones it was actually the ugly
duckling mixed up several different ways
and she picked the reference region to
do seed conductivity and then she did a
boxer wise evaluation of nine language
regions to look for conductivity to
Wernicke's which is your receptive
language area and what she showed here's
the word icky seed robins area 22 the
the preemies were far more connected
across the hemispheres both to Brahmins
area 40 and Broadman area 44 or 45 so
these are more frontal language regions
compared to the term controls they were
also more tightly connected in the left
hemisphere to Rodman's 40 so for the
first time showing they're using
functional imaging the preemies were
using more regions to get to the same
testing score or as my husband Duncan
says use the brain you have and so I
think they were using the brain they had
to get there when JP published said
sunny we didn't know how these
correlated exactly with the testing
scores
this is Eliza Myers Eliza was another
neonatology fellow she's now on the
faculty at Einstein in New York Elijah
went back and took the same children at
age 16 gave him a different task and she
was able to show that the more the
connectivity across the hemisphere from
lefty
22 to write ba 40 the lower the testing
score so if you were using that right
hemisphere connectivity it was because
you needed it to get to where you were
and so we concluded at this point with
the pre terms could have the same scores
but different connections were they
using artillery pathways or did preterm
births functionally alter what was going
on in the organization of the developing
brain and so our next hypothesis was
that voxel based resting state
functional MRI would show differences in
functional organization of the brain at
age 16 years so in the previous study
the kids were wearing headphones where
were pumping in a study they weren't
doing anything else we were recording
their functional connectivity in these
studies the children just lie in the
magnet on Friday afternoons at 4 o'clock
and we do what we call resting state
functional connectivity we also make
sure that they're a wait okay because 4
o'clock on a Friday afternoon is a
lethal time for teenagers
but we looked in this study at cerebral
lateralization so most people think that
several lateralization is a defining
characteristic of the human cortex and
structural asymmetries for language
developed during the third trimester and
these asymmetries and lateralization
correlate with language scores and
children and in adults with neurologic
problems and this analysis was done by
Dustin China's kids the newest assistant
professor over in MRI imaging and this
is how one calculates a connectivity
lateralization so in the first
hemisphere rotated is your right
hemisphere we put a feed and we look
where that feed is connected in the
entire hemisphere and then we looked in
the contralateral hemisphere and if you
subtract the contralateral connections
from the ipsilateral kind of connection
you get what we call connect
conductivity
zatia and each map is normalized prior
to the subtraction to determine
laterality and all subjects are scaled
equally so what Dustin showed is that
the preterm subjects had less
lateralization in left Wernicke's region
and right be a 39 and 40 at age 16 years
and you can see the areas in blue where
there is less lateralization in the
preterm compared to the term controls
and here are just the individual maps
here's just a graph showing that the
terms are lateralized the pre terms are
not but what does this mean because if
we're going to do all this functional
imaging we need to make sure that it has
some real-world application and in fact
if you're more lateralized and less be a
40 these are the preemies the testing
scores are better if you're little
flatter alized
the testing scores are worse if you're
lateralized over on the right side much
poorer so you need to be lateralized in
your left hemisphere for language to do
well at school age but what about babies
are they born with this are the premiums
born with this problem or is it
something we do in the nursery or some
failure of early intervention so what
about the preemie
so this is my favorite study it was done
in Stockholm and Seattle this was not
part of our own work this is a hugo
lager Krantz Hugo's been here lecturing
this is 80 newborns 40 and Stockholm 40
in Seattle they were studied when they
were 33 hours old and they had this
really cool way of assessing whether
they were listening or not they had a
biggie that was hooked up to a manometer
and the more they sucked the more
pressure waves there were the less they
sucked no ways and they listened to an
audio of their mother speaking in their
native language or their mother speaking
in a non data
language so it was always the mother's
voice because fetuses hear mother's
voice but either Swedish or English okay
and it was his left by the number of
sucks and this is very cool study and in
fact it was highly significant that the
babies were bored by their mother's own
language but when the Swedish babies
heard English suck suck suck
when the English made that babies in
Seattle her Swedish they sucked like
crazy so babies recognize novel sounds
and voices so Suppan who was a fellow in
neonatology and now is also on the
faculty here at Yale hypothesized that
for our preemies are very low birth
weight preemies less than 27 weeks of
gestation so 24 to 27 weeks of gestation
mean birth rates 550 grams that
functional MRI would demonstrate
alterations and several lateralization
when they were due to be born so for
instance we saw a baby in clinic this
morning she was born on November third
she was due to be born on March fourth
okay so that's like one of my babies and
she sue shows using resting state
functional productivity but the preemie
didn't lateralized for language so if
they had lateralized this is the left
hemisphere this would be bright red and
yellow but it's not because it's a
subtraction so that they're much lower
than the term controls so the blue and
purple so they do not language lateral
eyes for language and in fact if we put
the seed in Wernicke's right here this
green month these are the term controls
they cross right over to the opposite
hemisphere so they have crossed
hemisphere that's how your hemispheres
start to talk to each other so the term
controls right after they're born we
take them down from the well-born
nursery they have crossed hemisphere
lateralization the preemies not so much
and actually not much at all
so here
term equivalent age when they're due to
be born there's very little if any
crosstalk between the hemispheres
suggesting that something that you all
can figure out for me is going on as a
molecular level I have a little anxious
when John told me that that was only 25
minutes so I pulled the fly that showed
if you put a seed over here they also
don't cross the other way okay but the
good news is that you are all going to
ask me is do they cross anywhere and the
answer is yes they cross from the motor
cortex so here's the feed in the left
motor cortex term controls
cross right over to the right hemisphere
there's a seed for the preemies again
they cross so they do have the potential
to cross in different functions just not
in language so we concluded at that
point there were alterations in
organization of language systems in
preterm brain and that we could detect
them at term equivalent age but how the
best exam in these findings we fought
long and hard what is the control for a
preemie Joe thinks about this in the lab
what are the controls of the premium aus
so we thought about it a long time and
we decided that typically developing
fetus was the control for a preemie and
these are some of our fetal images ok
Justin made these fancy slides for me so
we knew that here's the term lateral
izing a term aged here's the pre means
that they're not lateral izing - well a
term equivalent and there they are even
earlier so pre needs have a problem with
lateralization but one of our
collaborators of Mariah Thomason who was
at Wayne State and who's now in Berkeley
and Stanford was looking at he based
conductivity and malaya looked at
fetuses between 22 weeks and 40 weeks
she put a seed in Broca's and she showed
that it cost the hemisphere she put a
seed in Wernicke's and showed that it
the hemisphere so we thought that we
would try to do functional imaging on
fetuses and I'm going to show you the
data on ten typically developing fetuses
on fetuses really for the first time
have longitudinal images we scanned them
at 30 to 32 weeks we brought them back
at 34 to 36 weeks and then after they
were born we whisked them down from the
well-baby nursery and pop them in the
scanner and scan them again and this was
over for those who have been there and
the pediatric magnet looks like a beach
they have big shares for the moms to sit
in and we did four 5-minute runs of
resting state functional connectivity
and this is really thanks to Sarah Cross
Sarah is a high-risk obstetrician
unfortunately we just lost to
Minneapolis and this is what I hope
you'll often see that in the back this
is what a fetal functional imaging scan
looks like so for those of you who are
physicists there is a lot of motion in
there I can show you that the eyeballs
are through their eyeballs right up
there okay so this is an axial cut of
this fetus so the mom is breathing the
fetus is breathing the aorta is beating
and the placenta is bleeding so that's a
lot of motion but thank goodness for
Dustin Chyna the young man whose picture
I showed you it took him six months but
he was able to get rid of all that
motion and so let me and he comes up
with functional images that look very
close to this this is he tells me super
perfect and if you look over here you're
going to see the babies the fetuses
eyeballs come through the eyes this is
an axial cut see the hemispheres this is
a 30 week brain so it's very smooth you
can see it come right up to the
convexity so with that kind of imaging
which is really a huge tribute to Dustin
because a lot of people have been
working this all over the world
you were able to do fetal functional
imaging because when it's moving like
crazy who knows where the signal is and
so the first study that we did was look
to see if they were lateralized and in
fact already at 32 32 weeks the fetuses
are lateralized for language and they're
pruning down their levels their
connections at 34 to 36 weeks so this
language region which we thought came
much later is in fact here in the
fetuses and probably here even before we
looked and so we were very fortunate
that Mariah who was still at Wayne State
but who sent us all her data to analyze
and us being Dustin was really just
being the supervisor sent us data on 32
women with appropriate for gestational
age fetuses they had had a fetal resting
state functional conductivity a single
scan at a mean gestation of 29 weeks so
right at the beginning of the third
trimester 14 of these pregnancies ended
in preterm delivery and the preterm
delivery the mean age was 32 weeks with
a range of 34 to 35 weeks and eighteen
of them went on to be term deliveries
and the most interesting thing that we
discovered in these data is that you can
see the alterations and language systems
and those fetuses are going to be born
prematurely so if you can here's the
fetal functional imaging looking at bold
signal in the babies the fetuses who
were born at erm you can see the
language regions here here's the babies
who are going to be born preterm no bold
signal in the language regions either in
the temporal regions or in the frontal
and here's the area and Broca's and
Wernicke's region of the highest
significant difference and here it is in
neurologic presentation so the left is
on your left in Mariah's stand here and
you can see this region in the left
temporal differentiate the fetuses who
are going to be point B born preterm
compared to the ones who are born at
term and in fact if you put a seed there
and see where it connects across the
hemisphere you can actually predict
which babies are going to be born early
so here's the connectivity on the y-axis
and here's their gestational age at
birth so if you have a bird conductivity
as a fetus these data suggest that
you'll be born early so this is Joe's
mixture so in conclusion I hope I've
convinced you quickly that there's all
the connectivity for language in the
developing preterm brain and that it's
lasting and predictive of outcome and
that in fact preliminary data suggests
that it's present during the late second
and third trimesters of gestation in
fetuses that are born preterm and so how
did that not go
mmm lost Joe sloth no he wasn't near
mine computer this all right when I
first met Joe he tough showed me his
favorite slide which is of this bridge
what bridge is this Joe this is Gareth
Erina there's an on barrel bridge and
Joe likes this picture of it not being
connected and he felt that our work was
just beginning that we weren't connected
but that if we worked hard enough we
would eventually be connected so Joe's a
person to whom I have gone many many
many times since 1984 he always gives
wise advice he provides the basic
science upon which our clinical work has
been able to be funded across the years
and he has my everlasting gratitude so
thank you we haven't tried that yet but
that would be a very good question for
those of you who don't study ivh we
believe that ivh is not an in utero
event unless it's a big fetal hemorrhage
with a known vascular problem it would
be interesting to see if there are
differences in the germinal matrix
region in the children who are born
preterm so we could look retrospectively
maybe yes
okay yeah so I said that's that's why I
said Joe can't the bridge isn't done I
didn't show this like in slide I I don't
know I think that all of you in this
room need to help answer that question
because we thought in the preemies for
any of you who've been in our newborn
special care unit they get hypoxic they
get hypotensive they get hypoglycemic
they get periventricular leukomalacia
but this is really the first paper and
it was just published that suggests that
in fact you can see this before they're
born and so maybe there's a genetic
predisposition maybe there's some factor
that results in preterm delivery and
altered wiring because of course there's
a huge overlap in the genes that cause
preterm birth and are related to brain
development it's just an enormous
overlap so I think for the next
generation of scientists this is really
the hot question
thank intrauterine growth retardation
yes so the people in Zurich and Geneva
have been studying IUGR for many many
years so intrauterine growth retardation
is actually a symptom and not a
diagnosis because there are many many
causes of it but if you just take and
these are babies who weigh less than the
10th percentile for growth at birth if
you take a whole cohort they have big
aberrations in wiring but many of these
babies are IUGR because of infection
because of problems with the placenta
because of the mother's hypertensive so
there are many many factors in there but
yes they have and they haven't had many
functional imaging studies but even on
DTI they're wired differently so some
external fighting molecule is not right
thank you so our next speaker is Adi
digression ER who's a MD ph.d new
mineral pathologist from Stanford just a
few words about Dida Dida was one of the
trainees in Joe's lab she was originally
a did her undergraduate work in Stanford
right Cal yeah Oh birthday ooh
sorry Mina and then was an MD PhD
student here at Yale where she worked on
her thesis in Jill's laboratory
subsequently she returned to California
Stanford completed her pathology
residency and AP and a meadow pathology
fellowship there and joined the faculty
there at Stanford where she is today she
has well you can read about it's in your
thing and we'll take
time is an interest in an unusual
interest I would say and as a Humana
pathologist in the vascular niche or the
niche that the bone marrow resides in so
you can put that on our to review and
I'm going to start the timer and whoops
we got from stop the timer because we
got to fix this time pressure where's
the keyboard so picking me up yeah
Jepson which one's yours
faster that core and the core bingo yeah
so I came to New Haven in 1996 and just
a couple of years later as an MD ph.d
program I had the good fortune to rotate
through Joe's lab and sort of fall in
love with what he was studying and and
the just the excitement in the lab and
what I've done in this talk is try to
show how that time in Joe's lab has
really inspired me going forward into
what I do now so as you can see I'm at
Stanford University now but I'm class of
Madri 2002 okay and as you can see I was
really happy to be in that lab sorry
yeah and I can see a couple of couple of
the reasons for the excitement in that
lab here of course Joe who was just
always just happy to be there excited
made a you know made everything possible
for us but also the other thing that
made that lab her wonderful was just the
the variety of wonderful people in there
and I see Anna and sandy em in the
audience here and sandy was just amazing
in terms of providing support and like a
huge amount of knowledge and technical
support for everyone and I has gone on
to get a JD and like work in technology
sorry she's going to be shy but I mean
this is these are the sort of people
that Joe's lab produced it's amazing
Lara's notes what
doing basic research you know so their
pediatrician in here Josephine and C so
is a neonatologist also at UCLA now I
mean just the variety of people that
just lab has been and has produced is
amazing and it's really a testament to
his mentorship okay so here are a couple
of the things that got me excited and in
the jobs lab way back when and so of
course back when I was there Joseph was
mostly concentrating on CD thirty-one or
pecan one and we were looking a lot at
endothelial cells and one of the things
I did was wound a whole lot of cell
cultures right just grow this Hugh
vector bovine your dig into Celio cells
and plates and then just scrape them and
watch them grow back in and try to
figure out why it was at the ones that
were missing CD 31 grew back differently
and we figured out that some of this has
to do with the item
no I Kim sorry it's been a few years
yeah the item the human receptor
tyrosine based inhibitory motif and
shift to phosphatase that sticks to it
and some of some of the things that
caught my eye at that time was the
patterns the beauty of the changes in
the cell morphology and the patterns
which is what led me to go on into
pathology so you can see here how at SHP
2 in the confluent cells is really sort
of at these beautiful focal areas and
co-located with P cam 1 and in the
migrating cells it really redistributes
okay there we are again did I go
backwards I must have gone backwards and
then yeah I've got it now we're going to
go forward in time and then the ADA that
you know just looking at these cells I
had noticed these changes in morphology
right so you can see that the T cam
knockout cells have these sort of
attenuated sharp edges where so the
control cells did not they have this
nice cobblestone pattern which turn out
to be a
seated with changes in cytoskeletal
architecture and small and rho gtpases
so that was so cool being able to go
from sort of morphology to the mechanism
of how these cells were moving and I'm
doing it again sorry I guess I can't use
that so ready to say thanks for
everything Jo we had a great time in lab
and out of it sandy
so there's sandy again and Anna with a
black you can kind of embarrassing them
okay so there we are
so I'm going to talk about the aspect of
my translational research it has to do
some what was vasculature I I do mostly
clinical work I mean he had a key matter
pathologist I run our fellowship at
Stanford to test for him at a pathology
fellows but I do find time for
translational work as well which is what
keeps me excited and going so I
concentrate a lot on my low dysplastic
syndromes or MDF which is a clonal bone
marrow failure disorder affecting one or
more Hamada poetic lineages MDS is
associated with ineffective
hematopoiesis which results in anemia
thrombocytopenia cetera and these
patients it's not it's not an easy sort
of some diagnosis to live with because a
lot of them are transfusion defendant
they can iron overloaded they're
susceptible to infections many of them
die because of these cytokine es and
aren't overload and the subsidy also can
develop acute leukemia really the only
way to cure MDS is with a stem cell
transplant but unfortunately most
patients who get MDS are in their late
60s 70s and on so they may not be good
candidates for stem cell transplant and
it turns out that you know when we look
at the bone marrow we think about trial
any genetic rhesus but there's a lot
more to the bone marrow than just in
metaphoric elements there's the whole
infrastructure of the bone marrow
microarchitecture and back in 2010 I'm
not going to attempt to pronounce this
right my markers at all publish this
paper about how messing basically with
a subset of the mesenchymal stromal
cells could induce smaller dysplastic
syndrome in mice so just by changing the
makeup of the mesenchymal stem cell
which starts to contribute to both
mizenko most normal cells osteoblasts
and and to the fat of the bone marrow
they could cause a MDS like progression
in mice but it turns out that when we
try to diagnose MDS and when the
hematologist oncologist prognosticate on
MDS and decide what therapies to give to
you MDS patients they're not looking at
the microenvironment at all we look
under the microscope and decide whether
there's morphologic dysplasia so whether
the red myeloid and mega carry acidic
elements are malformed morphologically
we count the immature cells or blasts we
look for set of genetic abnormalities
and then for Greg gnosis is also takes
into account cytokine ia's so really
except to some degree fibrosis the
marrow micro environment is not
currently evaluated during clinical
diagnosis and or classification so what
we thought was that there's something
here that could really add to the
diagnosis and the understanding of human
MDS so just to bring home the idea that
the bone marrow is not some sort of
homogeneous of developing marrow
elements there's a real architecture and
there are domains to the bone marrow
right so you here you have some
trabecular bone and we have these little
ink dots the restored colonies and
here's one closer up with a central
macrophage joint containing some iron
and it's hugging this sinusoid which is
sort of ecstatic and full of
erythroid cells so it's an intimate
contact with that element of the marrow
vasculature the my legs on the other
hand you can see these slightly pink
looking cells that are lined up along
the trabecular bone and they also form
cuffs around a different component of
the marrow vasculature which is the
capillary
and lastly to make a curious sights
which actually are also an intimate
contact with sinusoids and in fact they
sort of weigh their little feet into the
breeze and by their platelets off into
that sinusoidal vasculature and
incidentally I want to look because I
thought I remembered this but Joe this
didn't involve me at all this is after
my time but Joe found that in that CD 31
knockout model that these mice failed to
localize they megakaryocytes to that
sinusoidal niche really where they need
to be in order to properly but ugly
let's to the bone marrow and I didn't
read this in detail Joe where they from
beside a penis come I know we want okay
so they made up for it they compensated
but really cool nevertheless so I've
talked to you about where the maturity
metaphoric elements are and then I want
to speak to you of the other elements of
the marrow right so we have bone stroma
and resident mature of metal lymphoid
cells okay so here's our normal
trabecular bone we have this beautiful
lamellar bone that's laid down bit by
bit and ossified we have the unoccupied
ostrich steep seeing which is made up of
type one collagen we have our
osteoblasts and osteoclasts
all their adults who are the ones who
get MDS and a lot of the other myeloid
neoplasms we're talking about flat bones
for the most part we're hematopoiesis
happens in mice most of these mice
models you're taking a very young mouse
and your sectioning the steamer so
you're talking about a long bone which
is totally different
okay so adult human react press contains
these inter anastomosing trabecular
meshwork and they're about 0.6 0.7
millimeters apart with a plate thickness
of about 0.1 so you have this huge
surface area of trabecular bone where
most adult or older adult hematopoiesis
happens okay moving on to the stroma so
at the precise vessels reticular cells
so just to show an end with or at least
diagnostic motor pathologists note is
but adipocytes are a large component in
an increasing component of human marrow
as we age and we lose bone mass we gain
fat cells in the marrow so by the time
we're in our 60s or 70s at the prime age
to develop MDS we actually have more fat
volume than somatic lytic volume in the
marrow okay and this is in stark
contrast again this is a mouse femur the
most biologists here probably recognize
it where you have this cortical bone
very little trabecular bone very little
fat and even the microarchitecture the
vessels is different by because here
these nice longitudinal capillaries
which is different from the branching
micro vasculature in human trabecular
bone okay
so blood vessels are an organizing
principle of the marrow I already showed
you how they're an organizing principle
of hematopoiesis so we have two major
types of vessels in there these small
diameter capillaries and you can
recognize these on H&E because they have
a round contour with endothelial nuclei
bulging in they're allowing lined by
parasites or vascular muscle and they're
cuffed by plasma cells or maturing
myeloid and then you have the other
aspect which is the thin walled
sinusoids which are discontinuous and
gaping and they don't have that parasite
layer and they have every story to make
a karyotype six-term and lastly you have
various resonant matured modeling void
cells but macrophages are particularly
prominent and this is just a picture so
here's an immunohistochemical staying at
CD 163 and you can see your nice normal
try learning genetic releases and lots
and lots of negatory macrophages in the
background they tend to be attenuated by
solar cells sometimes they have more
extensions and I also did some
immunofluorescence here so you can see a
restored colony to that central
macrophage which we expect to be there
but notice that their macrophages
outside of the era's colonies as well so
that's normal people can get themselves
in trouble when they suspect hlh and
they do TB 163 and they don't normally
do it may go out too many American pages
no this is normal
meh thank you most Romo sells they
support the self-renewing proliferation
of cd34 positive at aquatic progenitors
and are part of the so-called stem cell
niche but most of what has been known
about these has been from mouse models
or from purified cells so what I did was
to try to go look for these guys in
intact human marrow from patients with
MDS and comparable patients with site
opinions so tested out a number of
markers inside the line CD 271 is
working the best and most specifically
in human marrow let me show you show you
that this is what I just said so we went
ahead and characterize these using IHC W
no fluorescence and some confocal as
well as widefield microscopy and then
looked at larger cohorts using a tissue
mercury platform and quantitating things
using slide scanning or photography and
image analysis so I maintained that
quantitative bent that I learned in your
lab okay this is what a tissue
microarrays for those who aren't
familiar so when specimens come to the
diagnostic pathology laboratory to come
informally they get embedded in wax
basically like this and then we cut thin
sections of them and put them on a slide
to look at so what we can do is take a
biopsy of the biopsy with like a 1
millimeter hollow core needle and put
them in a new paraffin block and then
cut slice cut sections and then look at
them so this is you can see this is MDS
because this is a dysplastic
megakaryocytes here in one of these
actual tissue microarrays okay so I've
told you about the two different types
of micro vascular beds in the marrow in
Mouse there was a publication that said
that by just r3 can distinguish between
this it's different in humans and what
we showed was that you can pick out the
capillaries very distinctively with
meskan and the sinusoids fairly
distinctively with CD 105 so then having
those distinctive markers allowed us to
quantitate those oops oh sorry I talked
about that later
I've mixed up the timeline here to make
a more coherent story but I forgot it
done it sorry about that
so we also then found at TD 34
hematopoietic progenitor stem cells are
rarely directly in contact with that
sinusoidal endothelium so you can see
here at cd34 positive hematocrit a
progenitor cell the cd34 is on these
little lipid rafts so that's how it
looks for watching and here's the
sinusoidal endothelium so expressing CXC
l12 so that's part of the initiative
then we have those mesenchymal stromal
cells i told you about and you know you
look at the bone marrow you have no idea
how many other elements are in there the
entire bone marrow is full of these
beautifully delicately carburizing and
as lengthe most stromal cells and
they're positive for both TD 271 and ALP
okay when I say full up I really mean it
they're in there forming like a meshwork
that you really can't see on H in E
right so they're aligning the trabecular
bone they're lining to sinuses sinusoids
they're in all the places where we
expect the needs to be okay and they're
in intimate contact with the micro
vasculature and and what this looks like
is different for sinusoids and
capillaries so in sinusoids they're
right up against the endothelium in
capillaries there's a layer of parasites
in between okay so you can think that if
you're a percent of your cell and want
to get out into the vasculature you're
going to be blocked by the CD 271
positive I must see except in a few very
focal areas that would be entryways and
only in the sinusoidal vasculature and
it turns out that the TD 34 put positive
hematopoietic progenitor czar in
intimate contact and I mean embraced by
TD 271 MSC s and I I didn't have a good
way to do this by image analysis so I
sat and counted what percentage of cd34
positive progenitors are in direct
intimate contact with MSC s and it turns
out it's essentially all of them whether
in MDS or in in benign marrow so what we
come to is this vascular centric model
of benign marrow where we have this
differentiated vascular
and lined by CD 271 positive mesenchymal
stromal cells that also branch out into
the peri vascular space and we have cd34
positive matter poetic progenitor and
stem cells associated with it and in
some cases they can be in direct contact
just through a very thin attenuated
endothelial cell wall with without flow
so the next step compromise diagnostic a
meta pathologist was to try to see if
there's a change and we had an
indication of this whether there's a
change in the density of CD 271 positive
MFCs and MDS so for this we had control
site of panic patients and MDS patients
and we just went ahead and just went
ahead and quantitated the density of CD
271 using these tissue microarrays with
associated with clinical outcomes so
this is what that image analysis looks
like you can get a denominator by just
excluding the fact and the numerator is
going to be so the red is actually the
immune has become well stained and the
yellow is the object identification and
so so we've outlined all these CD 271
positive MSC s very cleanly and can
quantitate them so this is an example of
low and high Fesenko most roma cell
density in bone marrow and in fact we
did find that there's an increase in the
density of MSC s in higher grade MDS
meaning your RK anemias with excess
class i guess now it's MDS is excess
class they keep changing the terminology
on us and this is actually an
independently predictive of survival
independent of of the prognostic factors
that our hematologist oncology
colleagues use like IPS sr transfusion
history and etc okay so now we have a
vascular centric model of the MDS marrow
right so now instead of just having a
few areas where these td-30 positive
commodify otic progenitor cells are
innocent or touching sort of endothelium
which is where the THC l12 is also
expressed we have
big meshwork of CD 271 positive MSC's
that are in association with the
hematocrit on others and the HDL 12 is
also turned on in these so that I didn't
have time to show you okay the other
thing we found was that there was a
selective expansion of the sinusoidal
compartment in MDF using this
differential staining for nested
positive capillaries microvessels and CD
105 positive sinusoidal sinusoidal
microvessels I probably should go ahead
and update this and put in some more
sinusoids as well okay and then I also
told you at the very beginning that
there's transfusion dependence and iron
overload our big problem in terms of
morbidity and mortality in MDS we also
looked at macrophages the iron content
of the marrow and him oxygenate one
expression within macrophages in MDS and
benign site opinion and it turns out
that CD 163 positive macrophages contain
most of the cytoplasmic h o1 in the
marrow there had been talked about this
being within other components of the
niche but it's really it can take one
dictated lee that they're mostly in
macrophages and then what we can do is
quantitate the percent of the
macrophages that rho1 positive by doing
sort of a two-step object identification
and then associating those objects so we
come out with this false color image
that shows each one positive and hor
negative macrophages so sort of like it
inside to flow okay so by using that I
was able to show that a few interesting
things about the state of iron
processing or handling and MDS marrow
first of all there's iron overload in
MDS marrow independent of transfusions
before you even start that I didn't show
you here and then it turns out that in
benign site athenaeus when they're
transfused there's not an really an
association with in greece it's a one
expression but an MDS you transfuse
those patients and their macrophages get
upset and start over expressing h o1 so
there's something very different in the
way that MDS marrows
able to handle and respond to iron so
that's really interesting I think and
that's all done with just
paraffin-embedded tissue and and lastly
that there was actually for survival
among these hl1 hi and BS patients so
having these macrophages with
upregulated h o1 was somehow associated
with poor prognosis independent of ips
esse independent of transfusion history
okay so i would like to say for all the
wonderful work that everyone here many
people here are doing in the basic
science lab it's really still important
to bring it back to the human tissues
and there's an amazing amount that we
can learn from those intact human
tissues and we can do it pretty
rigorously so we pathologists were doing
clinical work how much they contribute
to the understanding of health and
disease and i wanted to acknowledge my
some of my collaborators i've had a
couple of trainees and mostly joe Madrid
for his mentorship with modeling of how
to be a mentor that method i'm getting
to try that out a little bit and his
infectious love of the vasculature
[Applause]
well it helps to have the time right
here no this is all before sorry these
are diagnostic biopsies before they've
been treated yeah often there are I
haven't looked at that I haven't had
this yeah
but yes go ahead what would you do if
you could write I can say they precede
therapy but it would be really
interesting to see you know that some of
that correct we've decided being for
example I don't have the answer to that
yes
yeah I don't have the mutation status on
mazey I've took many years yes sorry is
it possible to get like the next-gen
sequencing results in some of these and
that would be fascinating but
unfortunately this is I put together
these cohorts several years ago so I
don't have that information on them the
field is moving so fast so something I
want to look at going forward but it
can't be with these cohorts yes so the
thought is that they differentiated from
the missing hello stem cells
actually well if it is then we're all
headed for MDS right because it happens
in everyone and that's a really good
question and it's entirely possible that
the fat cells themselves are the source
of some chemokines that dysregulated but
I don't have the answer to that yes
[Music]
you know I'm not sure of the answer to
that question there there's basic
research that addresses those sorts of
things and and their changes in the
proportion of fat cells versus other
types of cells that MSDS give rise to
with age and all that has been done in
in culture but I'm not that's not my
data so I'm not as familiar with it
yes sir ooh thank you
you know that's yeah you they look like
little guide wires like kind of like in
the cerebellum when when you know when
neurons migrate it looks like it's right
to that sort of thing and that's the
kind of question you can formulate based
on looking at the architecture of the
actual tissue but I don't have the
answer to it it does I don't have the
answer yeah yeah the chicken
one question for you are they the MDS
the cells are presumably we think of
partially transformed labels
transformers yeah they carry a bunch of
lesions are they the ones that are
driving this reaction it's probably a
back and forth dance right as a lot of
these things are in their subsequent
publications for exempt from right
muckers and that indicates that there's
an inflammable type of response that's
driving you know changes in the
hematopoietic precursors so our next
speaker is Olivier co-chair who's an
associate professor at the Harvard
Medical School and the Beth Israel
Hospital
he received his MD and PhD degrees in
biology from the University of Geneva in
Geneva Switzerland and then migrated
here and worked with Joe and became a
postdoctoral fellow in Joe's lab for a
few years and then after that completed
residency training and pathology of the
I Deaconess in Boston and joined the
faculty there where he is today yes I
think he'll tell you about today I know
yeah
Olivier amongst other good things that
he's done he discovered a protein that
is named pgz k1 which turns out to be a
large scaffolding protein involved in a
number of control of a number of
membrane surface receptors and I think I
won't say more because he's probably
going to tell us more about today right
very good sure you want to put this on
working which one are you
yep that one that's it okay well it's
really an honor to be here today is a
vision that will
- in the Pointer screen candidates I was
here and I was here in 87 so Joe's lab
was still pretty small at the time and I
was coming straight from Geneva and it
was quite a shock to - right here in
fact I had very very young family and we
chose in New Haven as a small safe City
and just before I arrived also he told
me it was never it was not really the
case but anyway we I was very happy to
be here and what I have to say is that
in Geneva learned how to work how to do
experiments but in Joe's lab and I'm
very grateful
I learned to think better and to think
how to ask scientific questions and that
was really important as I said we were a
pretty small group and we ended up all
doing pretty well after being in Joe's
lab and whenever one of us became an
investment banker in Geneva and I was
Canada I thought that was unfair because
I was supposed to be the investment
banker in Geneva so anyway so what I
want to talk about today is a project
we've been working on for probably the
past 12 years as we discovered a new
protein that we named PD gk1 and that
relates to the expression of V of the
HDL receptor the scavenger receptor
class v type 1 which has been discovered
earlier by Monty clear as the dirty ETA
receptor by excellence what I want to
say a little bit about the HDL receptor
and cholesterol transport is what is
particular about HDL is that it's
supposed to be the good cholesterol and
the reason why it's the good cholesterol
is that it takes cholesterol comparable
tissues which could be actually on a
plaque and load the HDL is loaded with
the wizard with the cholesterol and
become
I reread and reached in cholesterol and
then interact with the HDL receptor that
each researcher scavenger researcher
Calvi type 1 which is highly expressed
in the liver and in sterile the genic
tissues and in fact so it's basically
transferred cholesterol from the
peripheral tissue the liver and to study
genetic work it's the cholesterol reduce
to synthesize hormones in a process
called reverse cholesterol transport and
that process is supposed to be very
beneficial to us because it protects us
from actual Clovis's and cardiovascular
disease the HDL receptor or SRB one is
very peculiar protein in it so it's kind
of if you have B the cell membrane here
it's a horseshoe shaped protein which
has most of its body outside the cell
and very short m and Kibaki thermally
and this cavity terminal turned out to
be extremely important for us so the way
HDL loaded collector loaded particles
interact with the hiv-1 HDL receptor its
interact through the a for anyone a
pro-lifer protein which is the pediment
a for protein on on the HDL particle and
through passive mechanism is
transferring cholesterol from
cholesterol ester from the particle into
the cell what is what is and crystal
structures have been either i've been
sold for this molecular Marika's
molecules very close to the HDL receptor
showing that there is in fact a channel
within the molecule where cholesterol
molecules can be transferred so it's
very different from what happens with
the LDL receptor you remember the LDL
receptor is the LDL particle binds to
the receptor the whole thing is ingested
into the cells where it's dissociated
the collateral is separated and the
receptor is is the recycled in the
membrane which is that's very different
from the HDL receptor which stays on
membrane and work electrode is
transferred by a mechanism called
selective update the reason we where we
became interested in in HDL receptor and
cholesterol metabolism is through the
discovery of a feeling of PD DK 1
protein PDT k1 is a protein which
contains four so-called PDG domains you
see them here in color ok 1 2 3 4
and these PDT domains are present in
many molecules in about 150 proteins
which are involved in cell surface
receptor organization and and and also
cell surface membrane protein activity
and the reason we became interested -
they have been called according to 3
protein PhD 95 dl g and g o1 which
contains such pd g domains when you
align to the G domains together and this
is for TD g k1 you see that there are
sequences that are very very conserved
and one of these sequences is here it
can be NY g FS y GF g y GF or GLG of
depending on some molecules and this
corresponds to an area of the part of
the PDC domain which is called
carboxylate binding loop where it binds
in fact to the cell surface receptor to
that kabocha terminus of the cell
surface receptor that cavity terminal at
the interacting with the PDC domain is a
very short domain
it contains it's about three the three
last amino acids of the period of the
receptor and in fact if you remove the
last amino acid which is here Velen you
may as well cancel the interaction
between the receptor and the PDG domain
why do these PDC domain protein as
multiple PDC domain it's because the
function is scaffolding proteins to
organize complex cellular function
here for an ID in the Iowa cause of
Allah if you're missing one of these PDG
domain it's likely that one of these
interaction is going to be disturbed and
the functionality of the of the all
these receptors is going to be disturbed
so we became interested when we made a
PD gk1 knockout mouse and we discovered
that doing a chemistry of the mouse that
the only thing abnormal was cholesterol
the collateral level basically in these
mice was doubled in the PDC k1 knockout
mice and the reason why it was double is
that sod1 this HDL receptor was markedly
decreased in the liver which the biggest
organ containing s a b1 was markedly
decreased by about 95% and so the
reverse cholesterol transport in and the
function of the HDL receptor was
completely compromised there was also a
decrease in the small intestine but not
as much and there was no difference in
the internal gland or any other
steroidal genic tissue
so basically PDC k1 was an adapter for
SRB one but it was a tissue specific
adaptations in the liver it was really
important but it was not important in
adrenal glands when you look at the
distribution of lipoproteins in the
plasma of these mice you see in normal
mice HDL is the primary predominant
lipoprotein okay and in the PD tk1
knockout mouse there is a much larger
peak and we speak in fact is larger is
also shifted towards the left and it's
peak that very similar to what you see
in hiv-1 knockout mice so they were very
big similarity between the two miles so
in addition what we did them we to see
if we could recover the function of SRB
one using a transgene we made a several
transgenic under
and if we promoter to express these
transgenes
in the liver and here the piece of the
PDB k1 is that SOB line is almost absent
physically one knockout but when we add
the transgene we recover expression of
SRB one that's with the full-length
protein and we also decrease the
collateral back to normal in the
political one not about continuing the
transition here and we also normalize
the distribution of lipoprotein here so
P D CK one is the tissue specific
adapter protein that regulates asabi one
protein levels at the post
transcriptional manner and political an
influence on lipoprotein metabolism
which show its effect on SRB one so now
we were wondering well why do we have so
many PDC domain in PDG k1 and what are
the all these domains doing are they all
necessary or how do they function we
knew from previous publications that the
SRB one binding site was likely to be
the first PDC domain but we didn't know
what these other domains were doing so
we made a number of trans gene one was
with one domain that was not full not
functional we made another trans gene
expression a liver with two domains
non-functional 3 PDC domains non
functional and finally 4 pgz domain and
this one was functional with recovery of
normal cholesterol levels
we also found through another of other
studies than in addition to being able
to bind to p DG one and so what they won
was also able to bind to PG 3 but with a
lower affinity and we found out that the
world of p DD 4 which was essential was
not to bind to was not to bind to a cell
surface receptor or to a tabular or to
any other protein but was maybe it was
necessary because it was binding
necessary with was binding directly to
the man
- lipids in the membrane so PDC domain
at two homes one its association with a
sabi one for one m3 and it's direct
anchoring of the protein into the cell
membrane so then we did we wanted to see
how understand l OS r b1 binds to the
PDC domain so we did a crystal structure
of p DG 1mpg d3 with the with the hiv-1
carboxy terminal tail and the way we did
it was by creating a hybrid molecule
like that so what happens in the crystal
structure you have the SW one path died
here here here in here so we get ed to
tail organization of this molecule with
the SRB one peptide interacting with the
PDC domain here this is an artificial
model but this is a lot of people who
have crystallized PDC domain were able
to understand how the receptors is
interacting with a Pidgey domain so we
found out so the DVD domain in green
here PD for PD V 1 it's kind of a
globular structure that contains 2 alpha
Alice's and 6 Bella strands
it has also that carboxylic binding loop
remember which binds to the to the
carboxy terminal tail of the protein and
here we have our n sub e 1 peptide
interacting between alpha 2 and the
alpha 2 and beta 2 interacting with the
carboxylic binding this is a higher
magnification of that where you see that
the different hydrogen bonds and water
molecule and this is the last amino acid
of asabi one the leucine which interacts
with that y GF that i mentioned before
and we see that the interaction of
dilution here very important with the
hydroxyl group of the tyrosine through a
water hydrogen bond network if we remove
that hydrogen that hydrogen group from
the amino acid
we drastically decrease the affinity of
the receptor to interact with the PDG
domain so as I mentioned pd sr b1 can
interact with a p2 g1 and pd g 3 of PDD
k1 but that the affinity is much higher
for p DG 1 with a sub e 1 here and it is
here and the reason here is that the
sequence of the PD d3 domain provides
the the formation of a much larger
groove for the interaction with the SRB
one peptide than the PDC 1 which is a
very tight group so it's political one
at your protective you know probably
from the literature that if you make an
SR be one knockout Mouse these mice when
they are bred together with a p-- we die
of mica infarction because of advanced
atherosclerosis so what we did was to
break the PDC k1 and the a4 he knocked
out and you as you can see this is if we
single knock out when you add PD gk1 you
get vascular obstruction and you get
merica in the function so indeed PDT k1
is at our collective the next model we
were interested in was to understand
there were two things we wanted to
understand how it is is the carboxy
terminus of the HCL receptor necessary
in steroid or Jenica audience like
adrenal you remember that PDT k1 is not
necessary for the normal expression of
SRB one in storage an accordion so we
made a 19 mouse in which we remove this
is exon 10 11 and 12 s RB 1 the carboxy
terminus of HIV 1 is at the end of exon
12
we removed three amino acids that are
necessary for PDC domain interaction the
result of that when we use an antibody
that recognizes the C terminus rossabi
one is that the protein is completely
disappear
completely disappeared in this Delta
city that in that knocking mouse that's
missing these three amino acid if we use
an antibody that recognizes the
extracted or a loop of s RB 1 and s RB 2
which is a minor form you can see that
there is still a little bit when you
look at the liver as a B 1 in normal
condition is expressed in the sinusoid
membrane of the other side and it's
almost completely disappeared in the
recipe was missing these three amino
acid paradoxically the minor isoform
srb2 which has a different cable two
terminals was increased in these mice
and we still have to understand why this
happened but what we also learn from
these mice is that in adrenal tissue
looking here for example with an
antibody which recognizes all form of
hiv-1 and hiv-2 there is still a
decrease an expression of SRB one srb2
as there is in the ovarian tissue so one
of the our conclusion here is that that
carboxy terminus is still necessary for
SRB one to be expressed in normal amount
in stereo genic tissue and probably in
these tissues as other one is
interacting with a protein other than
piggy gk1 I'll pass another pee
difficulty you can see using email of
peroxidase that in the adrenal this is
the normal expression of a vestibule in
adrenal associated with cell membrane
there is a mud decrease in expression of
the protein here as there is in the
ovary and as there is also in the lytic
cells of the testes these mice are
characterized by an increased amount of
of collateral these are male female male
female delta chi chi nice multiply
increase with the distribution of
lipoprotein very similar to the PD GK
it'll be one knockout so what we did
also we wanted to see if we could create
another model of atherosclerosis one of
the problems with the with multicores
model let's uh be one if we double
knockout is that the sw1 knockout is
there still be the female external so
yes yeah it difficult to produce these
mice in a very high numbers shows but
this absurd the this sob wonder start
CPR for time so that's important in the
mall to make it eat to make it easier so
we produced these sod1
delta CT if we double knockout knocking
knock out and we compared them to a pro
in ecology you can see that in the
distribution of the lipoprotein to add
the knockout of apoE shifts completely
the profile of of the the lipoprotein
towards VLDL size particles abnormal
particles this is the FO heat and this
is the double here and what happened
that's what that was pretty impressive
is that unsure shall diet on regular lab
diet this mice this double knocking
knockout mice start dying at about three
weeks and all dead at between 70 and 80
days so ten to eleven weeks okay when
you when you measure the cardiac
function of these mice all these mice
these double a knocking knockout mice
are in Kalyug failure and we did these
measurements around seven or eight weeks
okay but what you see also in the aortic
root of these double knocking knockout
mice you see a large amount of lateral
sclerosis
you see vascular occlusion and you see
the development america
fraction and here vascular occlusion
using trichomes things so this is a new
model on shallow diets we don't even
need we don't even need a high fat diet
Western or pagan diet on child diet
these mice because of division of three
amino acid at the end of its rb1 these
all these knives are dead compared to if
we knock out which are all alive in the
same time frame
what is also a characteristic of these
mice is that the develop anemia as you
can see here on the blood smear the
develop also from both sides of Pina and
they are very very large spleen okay
that qualification of the size of the
spleen compared to the three other
groups if we knock out with a chubby one
not keen and well that mice this is a
double and when you look at tissues from
liver and spleen you see that there is
extra medullary in multiple uses so a
very striking characteristic of these
knives which all die by age ten week of
Michael and function that I've also a
number of hematology abnormality well
that's the result of transferring to
Mack conclusion and PDC k1 plays an
essential and dominant role in
controlling the steady state level of SR
be one protein in a parasite and
optimizing reverse cholesterol transport
so therefore is a very important
molecule if we all want to survive a
number of years to provide adequate
reverse cholesterol transport and
basically eliminating cholesterol
molecules from natural Creek sclerotic
black through the reverse cholesterol
transport process as a result
immediately when is a thorough
protective hiv-1 interacts with the
first and third PDC domain of PD dk1 so
we are really dissected the the role of
each of these piggies
demain and there are several proteins PD
the main content project which contain
up to 12 PT domain so you can understand
how complicated it can be to do that but
there are different roles for these PDG
domain interacting with cell surface or
or ion channel but also anchoring the
protein directly in the membrane which
can be very helpful
the also the PD V for domain is used to
anchor PD vk1 in the cytoplasmic
membrane and then the characterization
of that s RB 1 delta CT missing three
amino acid at the end of SRB one Mouse
containing a deletion on that Galaxy
terminus suggests that there is a PD gk1
analogue instead of genic tissues
controlling the expression of asabi one
and we still were still trying to
identify it and then the asabi when
delta CT ap knockout mouse could provide
a valuable model for the development of
therapies in a chiral sclerosis and
these are the people who have
participated in the work it has been a
very extensive collaboration with multi
krieger at MIT we discovered originally
as a v1 and that's how we got together
doing research and really has been a
very nice experience other people have
participated these people have done
ditalion like deuterium exchange to
terminate the structure of the piece of
the PDC domain retailers or non rotated
at different rates of deuterium exchange
and and these people have helped with
the end application of speedy g4 as a
direct interaction with the with the
cytoplasmic membrane so again I'm
delighted to be here and brings back a
lot of good memories and thanks for that
for your time what so so the deliver
deliver is not the organ that has the
highest level of expression of SRB one
okay but it the bytes volume it
supersedes all the effects that you
could get through disruption of SRB one
expression in other cells so for example
the adrenal or the ovaries and things
like that so clearly for cholesterol
control deliver just because of its
volume is is probably the most important
yeah yeah well I think it's the
collection content in the membranes of
these red blood cells is clearly
modified by the ayakashi anemia and
makes the deposit membrane very fragile
now we have not done half-life not
measure the half-life of red blood cells
in these mice but I'm sure the half-life
of red blood cells is markedly decreased
yes some words are written so that's
more difficult to read to learn to lose
them but yeah
I don't know about that yeah I don't
know it's play is very possible did you
need it you need everything with the
restricted area so we have looked we are
live at first we're thinking well it's
like I mean smb1
Oregon arises clearly in the membrane
okay yeah yeah it may be help him to do
that the reason we found out that PD d3
was also buying English everyone because
we made a mouse in which we we stated
TDD one killed the interaction and still
the cholesterol was slightly elevated
but not elevated to to the levels of our
PD gk1 knockout so we said well there
must be another binding site and then we
did the crystal structures we deserve a
lot of isothermal titration calorimetry
I don't know if you know what where we
measured the interaction of peptide with
the different domains and we found that
the Chilean 1 & 3 are interacting with
you asabi really has a nonzero well it
stabilizes so it stabilizes it's a v1 in
the member
there's your relation I think that you
know I'm not sure but I think it's
probably independent because the
cholesterol transport really has to do
with the with the structure of the vs of
U infinity change we have any
requirement of change now let's do the
end up at ecology gravity is a really
expression or integrated four-digit
local entity consultation so it's not
it's not miss localized because the
amount the total amount does really
decreases so but I think it's the
turnover of the receptor is increasing
yeah that's right yeah many degree
yes it's degraded yeah yeah well at
first we didn't have a phenotype before
we measured cholesterol we just didn't
have a pin attack
so I sub so PDG K 1 is also interacting
with the the Cystic Fibrosis chloride
channel okay
that's right yeah oh yeah this one it's
interacting with an ABC transporter
which is a plays a role in multi-drug
resistance so it it has it interacts
with a lot of proteins but what is
interesting is that slight modification
of the protein sequence of the PDG
domain is in fact changing the
interaction I mean the capacity capacity
of interacting with a given protein so
it's pretty specific it's still pretty
specific
[Applause]
and dr. Bissell earned her bachelor's
degree at Radcliffe Harbor went to
Harvard Medical School where she got her
PhD and followed on was an American
Psycho stalked her fellowship fair she
was the founding director of that cell
and molecular biology division and us
later the associate laboratory director
after that labret at that laboratory of
her life sciences in Lawrence Berkeley
she now holds the rank as distinguished
scientist there which is a highest rank
they have and she also participates in
the as a graduate faculty member of
Berkeley in four of their graduate
programs she is been incredibly
productive in her career with over 400
peer-reviewed publications she's one of
the nation's more sought after speakers
the list of awards that she's received
for this work is I think some are listed
in your program but it's quite a lengthy
list she's a member of the National
Academy of Sciences as you see the
Wilson award and many others her area of
expertise I think has brought a very
unique and unusual focus to our
understanding of breast cancer and
certainly was one of the pioneers in
bringing forward the idea and our
understandings of the incredible role
that the new at the Basque micro
environment around the tumor plays and
this has been particularly active in the
realm of breast cancer and our best
understanding event while she's never
been a collaborator Jo she's worked in
the ER least I don't think she's ever
collaborated with you but I shared
certainly in their interests of the
matrix and the niche around tumors and
sells shares significant overlap so she
thought we would be an outstanding
speaker as the keynote for Joe's
symposium so I won't say more Mia and
you get the whole hour so you don't have
to get off in 20 minutes the pleasure to
have you and thank you
thank you it's truly an honor
3d thank you John for inviting me I
don't know if you need it or Julie I
can't both I would have come no matter
what
so I wish I was a postdoc in the lab or
at collaborator vigil I always had
working but the problem is that I didn't
know any better because as you heard I
was a chemistry major and then a
bacterial geneticist what did I know
nothing so I come to do my postdoc at
Northridge lab I know I said in Vista
California Berkeley in the virus lab and
everybody was working with Russell ha ha
ha and it was such excitement as you can
imagine I mean in the early seventies
all of a sudden the first allergenic
virus that was discovered by drought in
2011 started exciting everybody there's
a refresher whatever whatever I do it
and I finally was completely ignorant on
my resume and I always got talking to
pathologist because in the days where
the molecular voltages were saying we
don't want any pathology all we have to
do is to make a transgenic Mouse and
don't know absolutely everything I think
to them are you out of your body do you
even understand what you say but you
think in the friction of the human
breast made by this bright clear kind
and those of you who know the pathology
or this
anatomy of the human rationale that blue
gelatin oppressive made making of to
educate yourself luminal my Italia and
one strong which is well blossom fat
when we find to our different cell types
in the breast we haven't published this
yet I don't know what to do because I'm
an assistant professor no longer
listening to me but he has created and
other people are imitating and I keep
saying Kurt you're going to get smooth
doesn't go anywhere ok so I come to my
lab and you can implement it twelve
different cell lines have to know what
to do in that structure and what do we
learn about that structure
Kiki not that would not a given know
some what region is still and you will
see because they asked me to provide a
keynote usually because first of all is
in lifetime work second I speak loudly
they're just my job I am large Italians
which is attendance because time is bad
for you and I have always liked each
other
I try to use my heaven but check off and
if I don't want coach as well so anyway
I can't work that and will be hampered
chicken will turn black in a classic
looking like this this was our normal
and he'll be dumping some rough stock
umpires as usual development now auntie
that didn't make sense to me
because you're mistaking how could you
just add one watering any so you know in
my own lab first of all notice that none
of these one acknowledges had ever
looked at at all all they were doing
even the MD was different
first of all while super professional
Raj discovered it in 1911 and 119:11
people really didn't know very much and
it's amazing because he took this tumor
dissociated is put it in a dish and then
injected a citrus back into the chicken
and 102 so he proved the cost per cheek
now before I go much further how are you
had put your hand up when you see
they're only four five of eleven
journeys you haven't heard me idiot my
phone is off oh my I know such as I I'm
doing decided I have such a loud voice
that I didn't need it I turned it out
when he was talking because I was making
bad stuff behind okay he needs it but
you guys were hearing me anyway I'm not
going to repeat myself okay so um so I
noticed that nobody was doing this and
we began to read the literature and
different some crazy stuff and postdoc
at that time and on and I take this all
work we started injecting the virus into
the chick embryo on a stage 24 don't
have to have time to explain I have to
talk to you about forty years of work
and and I tell a story I tell the
beginning the middle and the end and
please forgive me when I go fast because
I really like to get to the end of my
talk because I'm getting to be so old
that I don't know who else will talk
about this and most of the stuff I'm
telling you is not in the textbooks even
though I reread the drip field of micro
environment we invented
three-dimensional structure we showed a
whole lot of things but if you had a
former head of the NCI here he would
walk up because he still believes that a
single oncogene is enough and in fact he
is so adamant that he took my merit away
I don't know how he could do that what
he did no you hadn't you had it in 99 I
had a bastard when he hooked he took it
away I mean I can't believe this but
anyway I have a few young people in the
audience I usually just talk to them so
don't let people stop you okay so we
injected the virus into the chicken
chicken embryo and he showed that it had
the activity of the PP 60 sock which is
the product of the salt gene
it was expressing everything else all
over the embryo and the embryo was
growing and growing and growing and
growing and we published this in nature
in those days it was easier to publish
in nature so in 1984 they'd publish it
so nobody took attention at all and I
don't blame them really it was so
exciting to think about oncogenes and
suppressor genes and have one single
gene that you could have you know hang
your hat on who wanted this mess that in
the embryo doesn't do it who cares so we
have to do more experiments and we
eventually took like G attached it to
50-60 Sark and as you see that poor u
s-- federal every single one of those
blue cells could be a tumor
I don't know now if we take that wing
dissociate it put it in a dish overnight
it would pile up and make a transform
model layer of top of each other so
think about this we had the virus there
we have injection in the chicken you get
a big tube we put it in the embryo it
doesn't we dissociate the embryo and put
it in a dish it does it again what is
going on and what did this tell you or
told me is it a problem that context ie
the micro environment determines what
even a potent Honka gene can do but what
do we mean by context and how do we
study
now here are the things that amazed me
again about why I can't find answers to
them one of them is this good question
of why the chicken can supply embryo
dozen we have a very nice paper couple
of papers I love to tell you about this
but if there is time because I have a
lot to tell you so ask if you're curious
the other thing is I don't even know if
pathologists notice that we have
somewhere within 30 trillion to 70
trillion cells in our body think about
it it's more than their national debt of
US and Europe and enjoy everything for
today 70 trillion cells and what they
all have the same genetic information
all have the same genetic information
how do you do they know to do all these
things I mean look at me
this is this bad fit all have the same
genetic information how do yourselves
know so I began to wonder about it and I
gave a pep talk and I had 600 people who
were all none of them were scientists
and I had to make acrobatic to make them
know did you see it as they went across
or did they die okay so you do this okay
so how did these cells do it but most
importantly how do these cells remember
to be a nose and not turn into your
elbow right he could and you know what
you remember dolly the only came from a
frozen piece of a sheep mammary gland
somebody in Scotland took a cell from a
frozen mammary gland and what did he
make a hole darling now I rest my case
for those people who always say terminal
differentiation terminal differentiation
is a figment of 30 years ago or 40 years
ago
it simply doesn't exist is to experiment
very simply the dog what I just showed
you should tell you that they
differentiated the state is unstable
right so I began to think about all
think about Rocco on or ABC you have
cancer is a organ specific disease again
the pathologists notice but molecular
biologists have no idea
you still think they can cure cancer
with one single bullet and that's why
you're not succeeding if it's not this
bullet instead politics not that will be
dismissed well cancer and aging have so
much in common that is not even funny
and until such time that we cure aging
we can't eliminate cancer we could cure
cancer we could do all sorts of other
wonderful things but we can't eliminate
so that's very another figment of
people's imagination so I will spend my
life answering this question how is
tissue specificity nosiness l bonus
prostate nurse that the gentleman would
listen is remembered how does one
studied this program in mammal i wish
yourself law had mammary gland it does
how is the program lost in cancer and
eating and as I said when you age after
fifty cancer goes up logarithmic live
like this
and why is that and I haven't proven it
but I have a very good hypothesis and
how can one use this information for
sale well that's a lot of stuff to tell
you in the next 50 minutes what I will
find so I thought I give you the
conclusion first ok here are the
conclusions the differentiated estate is
unstable and the environment regulates
gene expression and is gene expression
is regulated at the level of the tissue
architecture
it is the architecture that actually
determines organ specificity
okay tissue architecture is dependent
how the ECM microenvironment signals to
the nucleus and to comity I said that in
1982 I can't tell you how much ridicule
iug including people who told me I was
like a never know okay if I start
telling you those anecdotal never
finished okay so if you do to the same
and I postulated because I had read the
literature I have met I don't know why I
don't have my 1981 review but I had read
favorite literature and I are shown that
in minute you take itself out of the
body and you put it in the dish you
completely forget women okay so I said
what is this stuff with constitutive
gene expression inducible gene
expression whatever whatever whatever
feeling no genes in your body
constitutes nothing they change by their
qualitatively or quantitatively and at
times quantity as in collagen and tendon
becomes warm okay so he show
architectures depend on that I suggested
that each one actually signals this is
Jeff I have written it before how are
you integrate and I said that it needed
to have a receptor the receptor needed
to talk to the cytoskeleton
psychological term hard to talk to
quality in a way that when you add the
ECM it with organizes I have something
up now this one thing I think you are
selling in one of the meetings when it
speaker and I've had a very interesting
discussion I will remind you but anyway
we can see not typically live ultimately
unified in the treaty FA naught into E
with in 3d
despite genomic instability and many
mutation you read this all papers and I
have even one before that the bit is the
best and vice versa it when he could
perfectly perfectly normal max put MMP
which are which destroyed the ECM in the
middle of pregnancy I think this
experiment with Nina work because she
was an MFP person and I was a memory
glass person so we clear the path
together and I need as I actually was
made in my life
the attach it to a promoter of a
lipoprotein gene called walk or way
acidic cookies it comes up right in the
middle of pregnancy image a mouse we
destroyed a structure in a little
pregnant in these crazy most part they
were nobility they started popping all
over
they started wrenching all over me and
as time went on they got changed
never introduction an oncogene never
taking away the suppressor gene it all
made tumors and entitlement okay so that
was 1994 95 96 noise itself I don't have
time to tell you how many of these we
did but that's the other side of the
pony
so I also made this hypothesis that if
I'm right and architecture is interacted
determinant of tissue specificity
then what should happen that we should
be able to change the architecture of
the torso and then you think it all but
then we have done both of these books I
don't have time for the Masters shaft
when I go to viewer interested issue in
a teacher in nature in 2005 and raised
by a direct register with no professor
at Mayo
that's easy
sighs yes you know it is and no time at
all in two weeks get you know increasing
amplification and also something so so
much for fellow
your poor thing yeah you can put it
there
I don't put it there because I get up in
the middle of my talk and I have to take
to do a little 52 on a single side so I
try to keep it I'm here all right
so so anyway you can you can see that if
we also change the structure of a
perfectly normal cells in three
dimensions and culture it it is starts
completely thinking it's malignant and
does all the things in the liver
themselves - okay so that's what we did
and their new conclusion that I can tell
you that some of them are not published
is that growth and homeostasis are
dependent on the nature of the ECM
signaling and lambing into nuclear
action in bread sauce okay the problem
in cancer is not growth the problem in
cancer are the changes that our chair in
architecture as you move through aging
and as the ECM gets corrupted when the
ECM is healthy you are looking gorgeous
but these things are not good for you
okay and as use age it becomes
associated split-up upregulate other
thing in this drama does the whole thing
so you get mutation mutation mutation
mutation mutation until you're blue in
the face you will not get cancer unless
the architecture is compromised
that's why cancer takes to a teacher's
childhood cancer is something else which
is a different beast altogether and we
can talk about that if you like but for
all this
eating population although I must say
guys as as early as 16 have a
precancerous lesion in their prospect
when these kids die of a motorcycle or
something is just get me they took my
dress and the prostate of Joe says he is
more or less my age except my thing is
younger if we will have carcinoma in
situ we would have you know all these
things that sells the precancerous
region will have all sorts of things
okay but we don't get cancer don't yet
get cancer which is the title of my talk
okay so we shed all these things and I
propose that these findings have
profound into the implication for
dormancy for diagnosis and for charity
okay so I was doing chicken burgers and
I was doing what glucose metabolism
because I thought this uncle genius
stuff is so competitive people were
killing each other to get the Nobel
Prize and they're all ones about it
anyway so it was just it's really a mess
and I thought I'm not going to enter
this so I said what's interesting and I
said Warburg was it why was everybody
has forgotten what Warburg or they are
saying he was dumb he didn't know and
here it was a Nobel Prize so I started
in glucose metabolism I swear I would
get up there with all the energy I had
as a young woman and all the passion and
whatever else my audience would glaze
metabolism chicken so we did this we
said this at least is more interesting
to them and besides we can hang it on
something that I care about my daughter
would care about and other people would
care about and our briskets so we chose
Melanie glass as an experimental model
because it changes it goes from virgin
pregnancy lactation involution changes
all the time when you take the babies
away counter are usually organized we
don't know how although I think I have a
clue and then it is ready to get
pregnant again how does it do right okay
here is a picture of a mammary glands of
human and we have about five or six of
these it looks like a gorgeous tree and
he said okay the good thing about
Mallory gland
up to that point everybody was a
studying group and you know why because
they couldn't get any cell in culture do
anything that was tissue specific so
they all studied good and I said what
Mallory gland is good because it makes
milk and it changes so much during
different times so I want to find out
like that so we looked at this I'm
visiting and that is too complicated so
let's just take one portion of this and
that was the formation of an astronaut's
and this is one layer of luminal
epithelial cells beautifully polar my
York tell yourself ever squeezed it and
this thing around it was which I knew
nothing and this lumen were baby sucks
oh by the way I tell you this lovely
woman who gave the first software she
she got I think I want you to examine me
because I fell on my head when I was
eight I followed my head well as a I
cracked my skull I went like this I was
tomboy I was jumping over a rope is a 15
year old boy and I cracked my skull and
I'm totally deaf in my left ear and when
pathologists look or whoever looks at
and not yet psychologists but you know
three other people when they look at my
brain they all said you have to have a
stroke because this side is completely
gone I don't I don't I don't have any
hearing and I can't remember any name or
dynamics as your magic today it's really
awful I don't forget to think about
science but anyway so we have we have
this gorgeous you're shorter and the
babies suck and somebody else talked
about that every time I listen to these
talks I think oh this is so exciting
that's what I should be studying but
unfortunately they only have one life so
this thing here inside is not so we said
great
and then these knocked we took these
cells put them in culture I think a day
or two days completely forgot
you're supposed to make note they change
shape they change polarity nucleus
change here they are here is very old
micrograph taken but when my post doc
Joanne a merman even before she came to
my lab usually former excuse all very
lovely organized nucleus half drachmas
secretory activity OG etcetera here is
the same thing in the same magnification
look at this nucleus and look at TT now
I want you to pay attention to something
this thing it's going to be the last
part of my talk
it is the most exciting finding we have
had so take a look at this I never paid
attention until 40 years later okay so
we do the section of the mouse here it
is an assonance fat chocolate and this
thing around them is laminate and then
microsoft said lament engine is part of
a basement membrane and whatever and I
learned from them somebody else taught
me about collagen I tell you I own these
kids so much
so we said we want to do this and ten
years passed before we succeeded we used
to make this tumor in my lab and I'm
sure you used to do it to I remembered
Joe I mean Joe Joe helped took some of
that - my husband lab people from
aknowledge looked at it and said oh it
looks like a basement membrane these
tumors secretions and I made this essay
and Lawrence Berkeley Lab would not
patent it and if they had done I would
have been so rich like you I wouldn't
have to write this big grant that people
who have either didn't give it to me or
took it away ok so we are the shell city
then you put this thing out and in no
time at all in four or five days you
make this even the sizes are the same
and he said are they looking bored I
mean milk is here and basement membrane
is here is your polar the most important
thing your body's polarity so we say
does it not yes fizzle gorgeous they
make milk the red is milk is beta casein
and we got the antibody from a person
called Shalu pizza and she was kind
enough to give us this yourself and
these are nuclei and there are two of
these things coming together and of
course I am getting older and older and
older and the kids did that so our this
concept are feasible also to human
breast because after all that's what we
wanted to do after all we wanted to
answer something but can't so I did a
big thing with my colleague oleh
Petersen he came to me with the young
assistant professor in Denmark
he was an MD PhD and by the way I'm the
only single PhD in your program
everybody is MD so you know I am
ignorant and say things that MDS
wouldn't say what I think we have shown
them enough that I think it may be
helpful in your practice too so here is
the reduction mammoplasty and the great
thing about that is we don't do it to
women they do it themselves and so they
goes into garbage and we took it out and
we dissociate it looks like that what
this doesn't look like that we put it in
3d look at it even the sizes are the
same so they make terminal doctor love
your unit very exciting and we said okay
normal cells put in 3d no they are
supposed to be normal can we take
malignant cells from a tool or a primary
malignant R or a secondary malignant
cell or even salon and put it in 3d and
would they remember they are malignant
and if they do we have an action for any
kind of normal
malignant human epithelial cells that
they are now behaving like human in vivo
because normal here was behaving like
normal so the tools would behave like
chiller and sure enough here is sing of
normal self it grows it stops growth in
in this Latin enriched gel
these are not single cells those are
like that propidium iodide and whatever
and when we put the little cell to get
them every one of them does it is much
having thousands and thousands and
thousands of human normal optimist and
malignant and these are clonal you can
take them out you can put a choice which
is our lake and knock out something you
can do that we have done a lot of those
things yes we do so I'm time we blew it
here what do you mean this difference
inside for new monomers because they are
not oh you mean this as opposed to that
it's growing right it to work is growing
in you after it loses polarity and after
it has about hundreds of mutations yes
if you don't have if you don't work in I
don't know in what jail you could put
them that they would exactly do this but
if you put it in a lemon enricher where
the normal cells are doing the right
thing the tumors also they act like a
tumor if you would any collagen these
are inside that and that has to do with
something that I don't advise what you
might talk and that is where does eleven
income from in vivo and it comes from
why your experience and I didn't know
that and it is so exciting so why you
tell yourselves do the same thing at EHS
similar or matrix' that's why this thing
works okay you see how gorgeous they
look no oh here so we have
Johnson and Pony it was done in his lap
but it was in my garage that I wrote but
what is it in people that does nice
windy with a rounded by fact and my
Appel yourself feel isolated luminal a
Maya failure self be put there making
gel of EHS of course visual cortex here
are this nuclei here is basement
membrane theories if you can notice it
again vision here is whatever we put the
same self luminal cells in collagen look
at you have completely incident so easy
and is not easy and is not easy it is
hearing those different things okay
so here there are no basement membrane
what you're making gobs of basement
membrane questions we have a paper
engaged to on cell biology 1990 we show
that these cells are making 100 ton 200
times more than this house of these
homology but they can't organize it
because the polarity is backwards ok so
here is the ECM inside and a specific
animation after now we come in and
admire battalion code and voila we made
a same this the typical cube of the
mammary glands
what everyone does it because why are
tell yourself go to themselves but once
in a while when they meet each other
they like that support it and we showed
that this is because only miles tell
yourself make the a chain of land okay
and that's why when the - cell utopia
closer you get to work your normal you
see how gorgeous they are here or they
choose five different one now we have
hundreds laminin is basically gone
because my affiliation from god or if we
do have my ethereal cells they go into
that function of reversal because they
don't make lemon are you with me okay I
have to go back okay then I wanted to do
comparison like why normal no and white
Elena doesn't know and we made a model
with all age where they had to spend 12
years three hotels from a real woman who
came researcher Mel Blasi they put
herself in a culture I mean if they had
nice 20 years ago nowadays get shoes
like that other book I really obsessed
me about Gila you know people are making
such a fuss and I chose those make any
sense to me but anyway so we took the
shelves they have put it in it in Elsa
in a dish no fear of no hormone nothing
except the little idiot and a blue blue
blue blue blue and somewhere in the
middle they came and took the EGF away
and I arrived there on that time kept
injecting it into the mouse it wouldn't
get tumor and eventually a tumor got
four and when we looked at those
different selves pre malignant malignant
whatever we had the first model of human
cancer breast from beginning to the end
and we have all of the passages it took
20 years and we did so many things and
we send this to cell and it took them a
year and then after years the reviewers
at all but you only have one model and I
said would you have another 20 years you
do it so really high they did I send it
to cancer research and again this is for
the young people publishes it it's a
good paper people read it these
different papers get get a lot of
citations okay so we put them in to do
their normal and malignant didn't look
different I put any treaty and look at
them package 60 p53 gone there is
association decision I did this which
over ate the paper Jim Alexander issue
in 2008 me getting amplified a whole lot
of other things go now here in passage
500 if you think they're normal now you
remember that chicken with RSV right
okay pre malignant cells when this is
the usual way and waited for about a
year before they grow etc they have a
mutation but these structure goes before
malignancy sets in structure goes before
malignancy setting again remember when I
dissociated give the header of the
embryo the getting transformed again
okay so I said here is a good mine used
to came from its same background same
genetic back these two an unwillingness
these are the million who have that
access it's drawing the way I'm joining
yeah and what if we found a way is when
we put one cell of each the add
something that helped yourself to
organize and we use beta 1 integral
inhibitory antibody okay and I don't
have time to tell you why what we are
very good reason to do that and we
brought the level of beta 1 integral
which was 5 times higher here than this
and they have easier for six on fire
they have this that everything they had
but the balance was completely gone so
we said okay let's use it in such a way
so that we bring the 5x or 6x 2 1 X if
we take it to zero they all died because
ECM is completely responsible for the
reason that your tissue cells don't pop
up all over the place
you take it away they all die okay we
have a paper in toileting 2 1 9 3 1990
1990
anyway 95 or 99 so when we did that here
is what we thought is a very old stuff
of course is not 100% normal but look we
had think we need imagery every body all
the information and that can't bring
down the beta ball to the level of on it
and these results they are normal we
have a stop growing they have all the
other oncogenic pathways
getting organized
really remarkable was in the cover and
turn off cell biology I didn't send it
to fancier journals because I thought
they're going to kill us but they killed
us too but at least they put it on the
cover so we said does one do it or all
of them do it this is the reverse of
what I have shown you these are the
malignant cells and these are the
reverted cells okay so why did they stop
growing so we started saying up and then
and then people kept saying all you
select it you selected I took I selected
ten to the six thousand three days
that's ridiculous
so we did experiment ensure that
reversion is reversible you know are the
malignant cells here are the non
malignant cells with the antibody
inhibitory antibody associated with them
in a dish with these without antibody
like that with antibody or like this we
can do it over and over and over and
over again if we take these cells as we
are inject them into Mouse from zero to
MERS if we inject them associated and
inject them with beta one inhibitory
antibody which I'm hoping very soon
would turn into a drug that we could use
with chemotherapy Mouse remains
completely normal and the tumor guys
okay so with the district says that
phenotype is dominant over genotype even
into yourself now that used to enrage
some people I go when I said it in
Europe they they gave me a clap all
right but why are people so surprised
they didn't give me a class they clapped
for me you have to excuse my language
device I heard somebody crack up and I
thought I'd better for escalation
that's exactly what happens if they are
a little bit going towards becoming
malignant because remember our to get
corrected if we add more nothing
absolutely wrong when you you you are if
you're adding beta 1c materials about it
there's nothing discover Oh to increase
it they become they become you saw them
yes yes it is another one go genic
password is like having so much easier
for okay so here is the big thing is
every one of these other people read the
one in the green signaling you added
that time zero to single cells remember
and they somehow get direction and I
will tell you how in a minute what's
happening to my time
okay so River beta 1 into green
inhibitor we said why did we stop fraud
we are EGFR inhibitors they do that much
fun is we do that th we college they do
that any one of those talks to everyone
else all the greats the signaling in 3d
there isn't a single thing little body
that is 2d okay so that's the source of
integration of a given architecture in
your tissues all right
what this thing okay I will show you
okay because they all talk to each other
okay you have to have the right balance
in order to get the integration but just
wait a little bit until I show you more
data because it turns on all these other
different pathways huh
oh you mean is the level of the
molecular thing get this surface as
Marty Schwartz and yourself I am trying
to tell you something else
I know it but I have to it because there
is so much under integrins okay for
crying out loud they talk with this
twist right end to the cytoskeleton and
I will show you what they do to you know
okay so form and function are related
dynamically and reciprocally now if I'm
right and increasing and I really want
to take this jacket off the rest of you
are falling asleep have my excuse four
o'clock in the afternoon people should
be having tea exactly I'm awake I'm
awake I'm just hot I was going to say I
feel bad for the audience because
they're not away and then he has already
okay so for my fentanyl related
dynamically on reception and then you
got here to me that if I'm saying this
you're all these things that were not in
these pathways like glucose metabolism
right so I said what about this watch is
do they change if everything has to be
organ and tissue specific directions now
in my youth I did this crazy thing when
I went and had my own lab I was amazed
at the way we do cell biology we open
the equator door pH changes temperature
changes this happens that happens
so I join Laura sweaty lab
after my postdoc and they had a lot of
engineers and together with one of the
professor's there about how we devised
what we call the steady state machine it
has two septum and B they're using a lot
of radioactivity those days okay
so we could put every ourselves we had
30 things and we could put the self
coming and inject radioactivity and then
in 30 seconds we could bring it around
on the other septum that open this one
and then remove the cell without
changing pH or temperature so we could
do kinetics okay I'm not showing you the
data but when we did that we showed that
Warburg was right that no matter how
much you try the glycolytic like Allah
sees aerobic glycolysis always want out
but let me see what I have here
no I didn't put it in but if you then be
said okay that's great because most
people were measuring like the gases
production without taking in glucose in
pitch it is like having a patient in the
hospital giving orange juice and then
you measure you know not showing how
many are in to the state drank but
measuring the urine or vice versa
doesn't work so you have to do ratios
when you do the ratios or what's up with
what is good so they were always high so
we said okay is it because of what
Warwick said which is that the hydrogen
transfer pathways are messed up well
they weren't because I have a first
daughter paper in science in 1976 so you
can see how old I am is over by your mom
right so so we showed using eleven
theory of Trillium yoga I had people
surrounding me when I was doing that and
my chemistry I wasn't still remembering
but be sure that the hydrogen transfer
pathways are not touched they were the
same and yet the aerobic glycolysis was
up so we said what is it is it a shame
it measures the shape it is you look at
my papers in
this picture 19 June also science
January issue and I and I coated my old
papers on glucose so when for 30 years I
tried to get somebody in my lab to look
at this in memory class
nobody would touch it then glucose
metabolism got so famous again it's a
big deal now there are all these
people's like you know who they all have
companies they are all doing whatever
and as a result it was very hard for us
to publish so when I added the
radioactivity in this machine and then
did a thing that nothing Helen has done
where we would take the glucose
metabolites run during a paper
chromatography I was that big and then
we put it in phenol tank and do this he
was the first system biology we would
get a pattern of glucose metabolite in
different sub
that's liver that's fibroblast muscle
looks different breast looks different
so even glucose pattern is organs and
selfish decisions okay yeah this guy
came to my lab I don't know what the
Japanese do this bless his heart
so this is normal this is malignant and
these four are the reverted things and
actually we have more we did our a
old-fashioned arrays it nearly killed me
because we were so bad at it but we did
it and he took the arrays and of the
normal and took 30 different metabolites
and put them at one and then he took the
same 30 metabolizing these arrays and in
malignant and as you see they're all
over the place normally took the reverse
and I'm not showing you the data whether
I will show you the paper that came up
they collapse in every case is collapsed
to this close to the normal when we
River so I said to him take the glucose
away so here are the normal increasing
glucose concentration is like adding the
beta one if you don't enter it from
outside it doesn't do anything you're
okay
there is still normal there is still
young here are the [ __ ] you take the
glucose away look at it and this is what
I had shown in the 70s that when I took
that glucose away from the pyroblast
that were looking malignant in a room
like what I showed you in the beginning
very beginning now if we took it from
there if you add a lot like 25 milli
molar to normal they began to mess up
and they began to become aerobic
click-clack
so here was the case look at this zero
one point one seven five all perfectly
good one point seven five they already
start growing five point five inmates
seventeen point five folks with growers
cultures at seventeen point five is more
glucose and B give them a lot of you and
we put them in a flat surface of plastic
that makes them like a wound all the
time okay so nothing like what happening
to your body
now this next time you have your second
cheesecake remember added sugar is very
badly okay so my two big advice my old
age is that exercise because it keeps
your ECM healthy okay you can't go and
do surgery because you cause wounding
and a whole lot of editing you may look
good and after a while you look horrible
but but the point is that doesn't do it
but exercise does it good diet does it
take away the added sugar and you're
ready and you will be really safe you
can do it still the things like doing my
old age okay here was a pattern when you
reverse and also has a parity if we had
hundreds no 400 for blue tree in
malignant cells and when we try to
revert them in one day they become
locked up and all of this is a lot of
stuff in here this came out in JCI just
between 2013 and 2014
okay here are the connection about why
this
all talk to each other I'm not wanting
you to memorize this but please just pay
attention to this here is EGFR here is
rate of an integral okay here is blue
tree which is the receptor for glucose
when that goes up those get activated
when those will go up this gets
activated and we discovered a new
pathway that people even didn't know
existed because it acts only including
it does not work in - did they switch
from completely the way they work okay
so we put glucose removal up there and
we said reversion is a dormant state
okay
how did the Shelf gone dormant after it
has to see so it took me many years I
thought until I had this brilliant oh no
before I do that I want you to go back
and read this picture in science in 2015
those of you who are skeptical they were
working with normal people but then they
began to sequence the normal skin as
opposed to the tumor every oncogenic
pathway was activated in almost
everybody I haven't put the data input
you can look you see that they're all
accurate they didn't have tours okay so
it is completely something here is
really normal - normal - normal - normal
- now we did this the opposite of this
20 years ago right here are the
beautiful normal self
very lovely product these are not as
polar at the apical for the basal is
gorgeous and they start glow okay so
this model that we have developed and
look so long is an amazing model it's
like the eye of the embryo of the
Drosophila as a model because to go from
normal to malignant you have hundreds of
pathways things that mutate and go off
and come down and do it going back in
this model from your malignant who
normal is one step
so that gave me the promise that we can
then solve how this three-dimensional
structure is made
how did meet so I have to tell you that
this molecule absolutely rocks if you
didn't have this you wouldn't exist and
it is as important and 50s p53 and I'm
being polite it could be even more
important as you will see one in woman
so let me just say a word about drug
resistance because I dress that is race
that we have quite a few things on drug
resistance Michael Gottesman at NIH
finally invited me three years in a row
saying the only thing that makes sense
now is this study because all those
things they did wasn't working it has
all to do with polarity we took six
different a poptart occasion they all
they're using clinic their use like
whatever and they all have different
pathways I'm not showing it to you it
was himself it was 90% done by Valerie
Weaver who has her own lab very smart
gal she she's at UCSF he came as a cell
in 2002 and you should see all the
things we have to do but here is the
conclusion that the thing it is not long
and after six beta for inter dreams and
NF kappa-b are involved in polarity
induce apoptosis resistance if any Kappa
B is way up
you're not polar if after six beta for
to the Hemi desmosomes is messed up
you're not polar both cells normal and
malignant cells done you put them in 3d
in normal gets organized dozen guys the
tumor dies and everybody said oh is
growth well we put them in collagen
where they are upside down they both die
it doesn't have anything to do with
growth oh it's the genome now no because
when we reverse the genome it's
perfectly
resistant so it is a model for dormancy
how is it that dormant cells get out sit
somewhere and
resistant to the drug and a patient
primary tumors its killed few other
tumors that are whatever killed but the
dormant cells are not okay so when this
guy came he's not Hutchinson Cancer
Center by um bioengineer who knew
everything about in the tl12
everything about bloodless or everything
I mean I don't know how this kid does it
you mind if you know I used to have
apparently photographic memory
and people used to always test me and I
was so mad all the time and then when I
fell my head I lost most of it at night
it's all good now I am a semi-normal
person but this kid seems to remember
everything here eats so this paper was
on the cover of July issue it's very
complex but the gorgeous paper is the
first paper having a model of dormancy
with human breast cells and this is was
what was on the cover if just listened
to me for a minute what he did was that
he injected first metastatic cells into
the animal at the age of 31 then he took
the primary tumor then he took the
tissues of rain ball and liver and as
month excuse me and that's where the
dormant songs were sitting because he
had labeled them and they had idea for I
mean even fluorescent fluorescent a guy
in it and you could tell then he took
another metastatic cells which was
invasive like ourselves okay and he went
to David light and fluffy injected into
the heart did the same experiment
exactly the same thing happened but he
knew Tish that they all come out and
they [ __ ] on the blood vessels nobody
knew where dormant houses they come out
and they [ __ ] on the blood vessels
within these tissues just quietly then
he made a modeling culture of three
different layers imitating what is in
vivo because we wanted to find out a
whole lot of things that they couldn't
do in culture and that's there
out of that 3d he has a layer of either
a blood precursor self or long
fiberglass
he puts her top of it in the tin
yourself that he has stabilized primary
human and material so that he stabilized
with a little virus so they could live
for a little bit they formed this
gorgeous structure these are the dormant
self but once in one we would see that
they make a huge tumor and because they
were new adjuvant cells at the end of
the dish that didn't have a place to go
so they would touch the thing and they
start sprouting the red off so he took
those he did enough with these he did
the whole of protein a face and did
everything he could show that your
laminin as I have shown you laminin is
responsible for the South to do all of
those same PhD was rich etc and he did
stuff here it is and and you have you
can see it in the paper about all these
things that actually wake that up and
look distinguish the difference in micro
environment boggles my mind it's so
local like politics right it's amazing
from door to door this neighbor says
this man okay so new muscular hits
Campos micrometastatic niches and he has
this whole thing with whatever it
doesn't matter I don't have time to tell
okay you can read the pic okay so what
on earth was going on you see why I
don't have mmm okay when I was going to
tell you about drug resistance I also
wanted to tell you about the fact that
we asked a very interesting question we
said you give life happiness to patients
who have a lot of high level of EGFR
right half of them don't reach one the
other half relapse in one
he cost millions of dollars to make that
right
and his probation page God knows how
much to have why and then I began to
change movies because a lot of these
drugs are developed in two-dimensional
culture and I said let's take with this
data these data here is EGFR inhibition
as you see here is the tumor here are
the reverses with the inhibitor - easier
for okay
I said let's use this as a screen and
let's use the morphology as something
that tell us that this particular cell
is resistant so what we did we made a
cDNA library of these put it back in
themselves to disrupt those things that
were enabling the cells to revert okay
to do that and we began to find in the
big culture like that once in a while
these structures so my poor graduate
student name is Eli and she is a Korean
gal and she did a beautiful job because
we were doing her hardcore molecular
biology they were just using logic
saying this this idea of doing using
this knowledge for 3d therapy so they
had some like that and it's a huge long
paper again this one was not into it but
what this one was in PNAS in 1978 what
that paper is he aiming in JCI again in
2012 or something like that and if you
look and so we discovered five different
molecules one of them was called time
eighty-three a somebody else discovered
some ad 3d your whole new family of
oncogene people didn't know exists okay
when we put it you can see that they
reach high level of time eighty-three
they do this that why because it's very
extreme of EGFR and pH recoilless is one
of the scaffolding proteins that
actually is regulated okay so when we
put it in the animals
there is no difference in growth rate we
can be done in no level of this are
added with antibody stop the tumors but
if you have high level they do not
respond to low patients so we did
another experiment we did gavage
whatever that some wonderful guy went
and did that with animal which they had
the tumor we gave them lapatinib what
happened son a t-38 goes home in a
completely different fashion
so here is one reason why the ej4 are
therapies one of the reason and i'm sure
there are many others we have for other
we have not identified because we didn't
have any money I lost a lot of funding
from the budget thing and from NCI for
the reason I told you this came out in
Criminal Investigation 2012 please look
at it I think it's very important for
people who do therapy they give a
pattern of tonight to ourselves
upregulate family retreat and become
resistant to all EGFR inhibitors okay
and the only reason they discovered is
because we did in 3d okay so it is an
oncogene family which interacts with
here at the f ck and confers resistance
and we have four more and the chinese
not have gotten interested in this and
are giving us money and we are taking my
kids back there to find the other ones
to see if a producer this was supposed
to be shown to you when i showed my
glucose stuff i have no idea what
happens to my computer between the time
I was sitting there and the time I get
up if either Apple or me but anyway
that's the paper I was telling you in
1976 science where I showed that there
is no difference in this pathway okay
now our it's getting really late
oh I just don't have a little time okay
um here he shows specific genes are all
there
how did we talk to each other so this
has taken about 30 years wonderful for
our graduate students who have worked in
these and we have answered a lot of
these question marks in 1990s we
discovered ECM response element and
nobody has paid attention to us in the
promoter of basically changing we showed
an enhancer and when we put that
enhancer to a reporter gene we put it in
the cytoplasm of the cell we give them
for election nothing happens we are
laminin nothing happens but if we put it
in the nucleus in other words we make a
stable transfection not transient
transfection and now we are collecting
nothing happens we add laminin equals of
164 so if young outside is talking to
transcription factors in the nucleus now
let's see how that goes
so this we began to ask the question
ischium here nucleus here somewhere
what are our own appear somewhere how do
they actually talk to each other to
allow formation of now so so let me let
me go back come on
go back you just messed up my top god
how am I going to keep okay so I had
introduces come to my lab very very
smart gal and I think I said this two
years ago when I was here so you forgive
me if there are any physicists in the
room but I say that the way to help is
paid by physicists you think they are
doing biology
they are usually failed physicists
except in the old days when they because
I have had physicists in my lab who have
been so dumb they even don't go and run
it Western blot and they want to solve
the problem of all biologists
I mean that unaccepted but this person I
have had two of them who are good one is
now his focus just got his tenure in in
Spain and this one is has become a
hotshot in a knowledge so she came and
she said Nina when you have a single
self and you dump the inhibitor
what happens I said well I don't know
she said well if you add it two days
later when do you stop not seeing your
response
I said 36 hours later but we can kill
the to yourself if you have a complete
tumor and a normal cell i doing 3d or in
life if they have made it is same
inhibitors actually killed the tumor and
don't kill the normal the way I showed
you okay so there is a very broad lesson
in reversion because we can discover you
through a few thick pathways okay
anything that rivers can can help you to
kill the tools oh and not normal so she
said I'm going to find out I said look
in a single cell in this huge job she
said but I'm an imager
I'm going to do it it's single human
bread stuff put in a gel did you know
that your breast cells could do that
it's either cell line I want to
Ursulines or primary primary press they
the minute you put them in a joke the
ECMA starts interacting pulling this
thing on top of the cell the if single
cell becomes polar it circles and
circles and circles and it's incredible
one cell becomes two two cells become
three they don't become for these revert
to extend
phenotype every one of them and that's
how you really organize the breast after
the babies are gone away the first time
because all the cells go away and a few
of them are here and there in this fact
which has the softness of mate reject
are you still with me
does that make sense here I don't mind
if the old people don't understand I
only mind if the young people actually
I'm sorry that was ending yeah okay now
here are the normal Emily's in normal
you see how they are attached to each
other they don't separate here are the
tumor they completely separate so the
polarity and adhesion are the basis of
the scaffold on which you make a tissue
so when we revert those we start doing
this okay so we said even if you're
right and it's polarity and an artesian
let's test them so when we take part 3
which is the polarity thing here are the
gorgeous controls here is the movement
like this we destroy part 3 or do
whatever it is you inhibit and openning
we do the same did it has hearing when
it's good it does this when we take it
away it does that and here is the gal
who didn't Hendrix and she now has her
own big laugh she has huge whatever and
people who used to see the paper and
seen women this is a revolution and I
would say meet the person who did it she
came from Trinidad and she is a product
of her micro environment
father was engineer mom was a school
teacher and ever since she was born
everybody looked like her it didn't
matter all these medicines we have in
this country and her said you are going
to be a physicist you're going to be a
physicist and she was good at math and
everything and she's brilliant since it
is who is doing some really amazing
stuff she just was at Berkeley I
couldn't go but everybody said amazing
she has discovered so many pathways
employed and so why should they stop
growing to make this 3-dimensional stuff
we now know how they do this but why did
they stop growing well we came up with a
model where we put very low level
make residual or laminin in collagen by
the way mate region has no secret the
important thing is they need to be a gel
of a given quality and you then add
laminate okay so we put the cells in a
monolayer we developed it of what we
call on top which in fact something that
a lot of people taught you on boogie
this lab invent invented what you
learned it in our lab so we did that and
now now can do experiment with the
sulfur initially in a monolayer and when
you are learning in from the top they do
this okay so what did we do we
discovered that there is indeed action
in the nucleus and you know this has
been a horrible horrible controversy for
50 years people have been saying is
stuff this sticks if does this and a lot
of paper even before ours have come out
that in private glass they act one way
in other so this lovely girl Canadian
came to the lab she showed their nuclear
action only can be seen at this high
level if you have the cells growing the
salts have a stock at a very low level
of nuclear action and either B or D or D
U which is a measure of growth so she
asked laminin she found that in two
hours which they go down the nuclear
action decide the plasma casting
followed and when the nuclear action
reaches that love all the surface
doctrine know as what is the beckon ISM
I only know some of it
soo-ji i 3 kinase is true exporting six
one we do whatever this is going to come
out in cell report we actually can see
the difference in half an hour
if laminin stops wrote it means that to
ourselves that continuously growing or
not responding determining is that
pathway that actually tumor cells the
responses
he what I'm calling all week you know
how hard it is to see the action in the
nucleus be fine
it's an unbeliever right well the little
that we have done we have done a small
storm we have done palm we have done
everything what we find is we find
single molecules of acting darkness of
acting and truthless of action of
quadruple of action where they go like
this they bent but what is the
significance of that you know we haven't
actually published those data because
I'm not seeing us to give it to him to
do instruction I haven't done that but
the kid that is now in Argentina I mean
in Brazil and has his own lab who has
done these he is actually setting up to
those to do those experiments and he got
his professorship management very well
now that's especially I put his name as
the senior author but he did all of the
work and whether he's going to get his
tenure they told him so I'm very happy
he's going to do all of those I'm
getting too old oh you have to
understand okay so here are this here
are indeed three-dimensional structure
you've seen how little act in Vietnam if
you put an actin in here which doesn't
have the exit tank to get up okay tell
your mutation I can't get up the surf
zone stock roll so you look act like
this if you reverse yourself they do
that okay so you have to bring the level
of actin to a certain thing acting is
not known as the transcription factor is
in all of the different kind of
transcription complexes inside the
nucleus you are ravening
in Newtonian all acting comes off these
transcription factors act very
differently we have shown for stat3 and
stat5 that that when we are landing in
those things you know and then they
allow the milk protein to get produced
so this is a very lovely paper and you
will okay now I have talked all this
time
and I have told you about this beautiful
beautiful three-dimensional thing still
what is the pathway how did they part of
all the we close the loop so this lovely
gal said there has to be micro RNA and
this paper is now being reviewed in life
it's this big
the only journal that would probably be
send it to make sure and they said it's
too long make it into three papers we
decided not so we kept it together and
ascended so alright now you remember
this remember all the reversions so she
made a regular array and then she made
micro RNA add fate of the library of
micro RNA actually and the long and
short of the day she had ten of them
that were regulating these different
molecules that were in common with all
of the reversion in other words we
revert with beta bonds we get reversion
we reverse we do form we get reversion
etc turn in each of them that we do that
arrays arrays are not the same they are
doing it by different way but the end
result is the same okay
they integrate in a very interesting way
I mean our cells have all those
limitations right okay so she said what
do they have in common
another postdoc did that we have
published it 7250 molecules income I'm
going way over my time although it's not
pacified but but this tree she made
antibody to open then they the tree that
were hi to her and were low in normal
she decided she would look at them and
see what happens
she puts this micro RNA in the tumor
cells they reversed and used to come up
she puts this one in there those two
come up just rather I have been telling
you hey so I did this for you quickly
it's me or 34c military and we're 144
what do they regulate down here they
regulate two very nicely transcription
factors
and I will tell you each of them doses
up the stream Huxley 10 has to go up in
order for them to be normal and if Kappa
B has to come down
okay now 90,000 people 900,000 papers
whatever who has actually looked at the
activity and what regulates p53 in the
live tissue right I don't think we know
cccc was recommended laminin 5 laminin
one one one regulates laminin five
learning five through a series of 10
right vehicle s p53 p53 regulates
laminin five and then laminin one
they're all dynamical reciprocal and
each to upregulate mmp-9 mmp-9 destroys
laminin right we have a whole paper in
gene and development when we modulate
that the cells revert when we put it in
they become disorganized the whole
pathway like this is dynamic reciprocal
and has all these things it doesn't
matter what this thing okay so those ECM
signaling direct chromatin structure how
I said that it has to be both by
chemical and mechanical and remember
that little hole I showed you in the
beginning in my a.m. those of you who
were here remember that very first slide
I showed you in so we kept looking at
these things and I began to collaborate
with this guy a German guy who is a real
imager that absolutely everything so to
have taken 12 years but he published it
on the top of your own self science
January 1st of this year and there were
reason for that we hadn't send it
anywhere else but that issue is all
about three dimension and I wrote the
introduction for it so I thought why not
people should see how this whole thing
occurs so we started looking at these
right
and we saw they have cytoskeleton in
them the cytoskeleton molecule so
Manfred ones rights and they did a whole
lot of thing and God knows how many
pixels this is the size that this is not
two nuclei remember the nuclear matrix
is here these are nuclear life which
this model God created and let me show
it to you and how it happened it just
gives me goosebumps the cytoskeleton
which from one end talks to each end at
the other end talks to this nucleus goes
through and here there are a whole lot
of little things that combine with the
Sun protein that people had showed or
connected to their to the chromatin and
it's just like that it's like a doughnut
did you know that it's absolutely
believable my mind we don't know the
details of this you know how much work
this is going to require in the future
people have to think of a nucleus not as
a single entity in itself is part of the
whole form and function relate to each
other dynamically and reciprocally and I
tell you here are the double storm
things showing that carotenes and
someone actually go into the same thing
from sweden nucleus and here is a little
model one of my former of technicians
who became my graduate student before
actually mate okay so here you have this
ECM then you have the receptors the
receptors talk to the cytoskeleton and
cytoskeleton have interaction with how
the chromatin reorganizes and now it's
the dynamic reciprocity of signaling
between gays and God knows how much is
in between okay took a lot for your
student everybody else is a student is
too
to students so here it goes like that I
tell you I cannot die happy I am serious
I've taken 40 years still not in your
textbook bubbles one month wide the
people who write the textbooks are
either interested in an own result or
they are not intelligent enough or are
willing enough to change their mind
we need a new textbook and I don't have
time to write it ok water penetrating on
the beach from a NASA satellite and
coral look at that here is a whole mount
of the mammary gland so I like to submit
to you that we know everything about the
genome we know the language of the
genome the alphabet of the genome as
primary letters of the genome I used to
be the director of ology at Lawrence
Berkeley Lab and I the first human
genome actually was being sequenced
underneath I referred the director of
the whole thing it didn't happen at NIH
at having a deal
and we were one of the primary goe
laboratories I started sequencing and
then three of them got together
including Livermore and Los Alamos this
treemaker Center the center is at
Berkeley and it was under me and I kept
saying to them I can't go and talk to
Congress and say everything will be
answered it answers a lot it hasn't told
us a lot but look at the wing of a
butterfly that pattern those things all
have the same thing look at your finger
and your nose look at yourself in the
mirror in the mirror you're a miracle
there is wisdom in you knows please
listen to your mouth use wisdom in your
liver
that's why evolution has done it over
the years and the architecture is the
message and in salute to Joe what makes
the architecture the easier
and whole lot of other things so what an
opportunity for the young and the
passion is all that's me a whole new
horizon to explore so go to it don't say
this side it is Nina did it what wonder
who did that person David Joe Guidice do
it okay do it and I couldn't get grant
for 16 years and is still taking my
money away but it has been a wonderful
journey has been difficult and I will
show you my favorite cartoon I always
show so so the guy you know I used to be
the cat you see that fish and these were
the authorities now the fact thing is I
have become an authority so don't listen
to honest-to-god because I would welcome
a change in this model a change in this
way of thinking somebody else can come
and work with you anybody in that
audience and we could modify it because
move it we could elevate it so it's
that's how it is right so this used to
be my my group now I have about that
much and that's much it and I put up oh
that's the kid who did the action and I
give them all halos except myself
because they have done a lot and I wish
I could have talked to you about the
election did you see that collecting
paper read it on the cover of ten years
last year it's so beautiful this guy did
it and you know it's professor in India
okay there's my family and I don't have
five kids at five grandchildren I have I
have four two from my son and used to
look for my daughter and my hubby was
the head of the GI at San Cisco I always
thank them and I say I think they still
like me despite the fact I have been
working all the time okay and this is
larger tricky lab which is decidedly
it's not livable okay they don't have
this they don't say
whatever they don't do the kind of
biology we do and should I tell them my
joke again
okay so they took the Dome of the first
accelerator that smashed an atom and put
it on the top of the advanced light
source oh I'm sure you know about this
then you do a lot of short serology here
and I say to people the physicists know
the difference between Livermore and
Berkeley but even secretaries of
energies mix yourself so at the end of
my talk so I say to them what does this
remind you of a breast Hey
so all your woman gets away with this
anyway especially but what the business
is not raised to be me nervous on this
thing for 20 years and it never occurred
to us now we can look at it without
until you can't divorce you know okay
thank you very much
[Applause]
we're very good audience very patient
but he allowed me to talk a little bit
more and thank you very much they heard
the whole story so I'm happy about that
and as everyone you know the 400 papers
they are not all good so ha so but you
can you can go and find out what every
one of these a few papers and support
them further okay yeah thank you very
much for a very personal we're going to
have recession afterwards so you'll be
there so let me hold question people
think we need pictures so will you
please come up here Joe come here and
somebody take a picture of the two of
them and I pray out of the way we should
get a picture with all seizures but Joe
is just wanting to give you this
basically thank you Joe from the faculty
from the staff from the students here in
the department at Yale because as you
think today I thank you can such a
mentor
[Applause]
oh man
Joe has slides - we can't talk without
slides only the one now you know what a
good nice position to say hmm
okay well as you can see a at 42 years
here at Yale all of them in the
pathology department all the morning
with two chitters Vince who will hire me
even we had second thoughts yeah still
goes Mike for a few years and then John
it's been really a pleasure for me
they've been ups and downs but by
project it's been really a wonderful
ride for me
I've done things and met people and
never thought I would just like to say a
few words and then we can get to the
drinks I really like to thank my family
and this is my life partner my soul mate
for 50 years that's Lucile and stayed
with me for 50 years which is remarkable
and of itself she keeps me grounded and
lets me have some semblance of normalcy
on occasion have a son Ganner who you'll
need at the reception an athlete four
years old he got married five years ago
expecting their first child a daughter
band is a musician and an excellent
carpenter in construction
other pieces of furniture for us come to
the house when the agency's nutcases
convention marvelous God you trained
together in Taekwondo and it was the
only time they've been hit me when I
wouldn't hit it back
the daughter Jessica who Mary called
Hagman when md/phd is two meters to
Fonda with Jack Rose misses lab and I'm
Draxler
and Gayle for 10 years I figured he was
okay at that time to marry my daughter
I told him he hurt my daughter I would
kill knows that they have a beautiful
boy Willem who's 7 years old now use an
absolute joy it's just marvelous
I missed a lot of Daniels uplinking and
Jessica's you'll and I get to see what
it was like from you lo so they really
are really the mainstays of what keeps
me going
we all stand on the shoulders of those
who went before us and I had three
wonderful measures and my graduate
training joking Shannon joking hands up
here at st. John's and the Masters of
Joe it was really a true gentleman and
scholar just an excellent teacher and I
aspire to be his his his attitude about
teaching and I you were in at John's at
that students in the second floor of the
chemistry building Jerry Jenkins was my
mentor Kelly was an entomologist
stranded in Oxford and Maine clean Jerry
Terry taught me was independence I
showed up at man and told me to get it
important man
no one else in there was working on I'm
going to Oxford freaking monster takes
about lab was very helpful in the
postdocs and faculty and department very
very helpful and the last meg do I had
it was last fourth minor he revealed and
those of you who know I know he was a
hard man meant when he said saving that
incredibly critical but incredibly loyal
and helpful when I started a lab here in
here he gave you technician thank you I
gave you a lot of major equipment
company got me started so I really owe a
lot to to to Heinz while I was at Yale I
found of the incredible interactive
place and there's really no boundaries
it can working with other labs and early
on I started to work with people in
technologies
I'm the University I record it would be
great innocent Silverbacks in the
department came bollock John Mara will
publish together on for one second hard
to believe and lately especially is
Dmytro sprout during summer some work
with NTP one I then got to know a lot of
people in the Medical Center and the
University and really have some
long-term collaboration to the chin
Jamieson with moment in the Pediatrics
quality development we do a reward for
your project basically and we have a
program project for four iterations
actually marvelous and housing audacity
energy pepper another neonatologist is
interested in diabetes and heart
development that gave us a project for a
number of years the people here pretty
powerful pleasure for me to do this I
can't say enough about other public
people in the lab many pelvis eloquently
ladies and at night he would sit on my
Apple computer and we would think about
like you had a comfortable and we had a
folder was labeled campus hang on that I
basically became a lexicon
pharmaceuticals and I had a 25-year
association that we were flexing on
Lenny speaks with ruolin's and the seven
other people Alexei on and really
enabling me to learn about compliment
someone I could never get fun before and
actually do some good with patients the
postdocs fellows and texts and students
in the lab we have the driving force for
the letter and you know I can take some
credit but minor credit credit for for
what's gone on in the lab they really
give a driving force and really the soul
of the lab and a couple of more sitting
here olivier ether and
you know there many many more and
somewhere near your perception black
it's a reasonably good list that
postdocs were just really often much too
tacular sorry booth fact any
governmental Elias the daughter your son
on a neutral project the students are
just spectacular gaming creation ether
is one of them just really wonderful
people
Anna's here really added so much to the
lab undergrads my first experience with
undergrads was it you know I've had
thirty undergrads of the LANAP they're
just incredible your place assertive
uninhibited and they've opened on many
of them very went off what three no I
had to pay some which was money well
spent on what a lot of we see if they'd
be silliman work published three papers
with this went to med school came back
as a pediatric surgery here at Yale
interesting already done very well
[Music]
okay all right
where was I doesn't matter a technical
staff there the sole of the technology
history of the lab I mean SPI you do
some things but you forget those I know
a little protein chemistry a little
tissue culture but the people coming in
really know this stuff and I've had
wonderful people throughout the whole
career here Mary Davis and Adeline truck
Irwin lad for over two decades we were
supposed to be tired together which is
food and repelling the last 10 or 12
years has been with Sandra Canosa
and might be shot these are really
impressive people sandy is a lab manager
was wonderful she really was the
intellectual mother committed the
undergrads in the lab and Mike with our
mouse studies we had seven or eight
strands going on
Mike could handle the wall and with a
smile and always bringing in vo still
nuts and we makes his own ice cream we
had guinness ice cream highly
recommended administrative staff
transform a wonderful person helped me
with a lot of the editorial processes i
had to go through with it different
journals with their teaching and plan
incredibly loyal i swear she take a
bullet room kareem brewery replaced fran
F machine tired and she's just an upbeat
wonderful person takes on anything with
the gusto and now recently carrying
metals at the transition from life lab
shrinking and losing the teaching stuff
but it's not a wonderful job I really
owe a lot to everybody here and the
other thing I can say to you everyone is
thank you all it's really been a
wonderful ride smoothly around for
number of years we got funding now for
this new project and so I ain't dead yet
you
[Applause]
[Music]